anger is reaching into a pile of hot
coals to throw them at the other person
you may or may not hit them but you're
going to burn yourself for sure I
represent victims of domestic violence
and I represent perpetrators of domestic
violence you spend enough time in the
room with people and you start to figure
out that like they're just hurt people
hurting people and sometimes it's really
obvious like oh yeah he's sleeping with
his secretary okay you haven't slept
with him in four years what was he
supposed to do the line of Good and Evil
runs through the human heart and all
marriages end all of them they end in
death or they end in divorce there are
people that are not meant to be together
I've been a divorce lawyer for 23 years
and I'm divorced myself I believe in
divorce so why is it do you think that
most relationships
[Music]
fail Jim Sexton publicly known as James
Sexton welcome to the iced coffee hour
that's great I was excited to be here I
I love you guys content and I I actually
was really excited when you reached out
so we're super stoked to have you on we
saw the soft white underbelly interview
we saw Lex Freedman and they've just
absolutely blown up people love you they
love hearing all the tea the drama about
why people get divorced how settlements
happen and they love you too yeah it's
kind of funny to me I I didn't think I
was that interesting you know mostly the
judges of the state of New York have to
tolerate me and I didn't really know
that it was going to catch fire the way
that it did I did a lot of Media stuff
when my book came out in 2019 you know I
do segments for Access Hollywood and
some of the other shows every now and
then where I talk about celebrity
divorces and things like that but I
hadn't really you know I have a
full-time job you know being a divorce
lawyer is like more than a full-time job
it's it's a really really agonizing
constant grind it applies to so many
people because practically everyone is
in a relationship yeah almost everyone
at some point will get married half of
those will end in divorce and even
before this like you were giving me
great advice of just keeping a
successful marriage together yeah it's a
tremendous equalizer it's it's not a
rich person's problem it's not a poor
person's problem it's everybody
everybody again heterosexual you know
same-sex couples everything like we all
have this desire for love and connection
care bonds figuring out that permutation
and and it's one of those problems that
like having an abundance of resources
only makes you slightly better or maybe
slightly worse at it like there's not
like oh rich people have much better
marriages or poor people have much
better marriages like there there's
nothing out there that suggests that in
any really significant statistically
significant way so I think it is
something that it's got a very broad
audience where all of us whether we're
people who are in unhappy marriages and
want toar about what divorce looks like
or people that want to avoid having an
unhappy marriage or people who are
single and going who should I be looking
for and pairing with in order for me to
not have those kinds of problems I think
that's a very big basket of people out
there so I I I'm surprised by it I'm
gratified by it but I guess when I think
about it I get it so we'll get into the
recipe of having a wonderful and
successful relationship but first we got
to know what is the craziest divorce
you've ever settled or like the muddiest
divorce I mean I've been doing this for
23 years so I have seen some amazingly
good people at their absolute worst I
mean I've had people who you know I I've
watched The Other Side just emulate
themselves and end up in jail you know
over how much they dislike yeah I've had
people who VI you violate court orders I
mean I would say for from my
perspective the the disliking someone
else so much especially someone you used
to love right like that's the thing that
makes it weird
everybody's got like a culated enemies
list maybe of people that you go I don't
care for that but it's rarely someone
who at some point you went hey there's
eight billion people in the world and I
want this one to be my partner so when
that goes south it's like intimacy
weaponized and so that often I would
think you would it would bring out like
softness in you like I'm a divorced man
myself my ex-wife you know is one of the
great loves of my life like she has a
tremendous place in my heart still like
we weren't right for for each other like
we're both happily in other
relationships now she's been remarried
for 12 years but we have a tremendous
amount of affection for each other you
know um I've never had an ex that I
looked at and went like I hate them like
I've never hated anybody but I get it
because if you get betrayed by someone
who you deeply deeply trusted that can
create a a violent sense of like anger
right so I get it so does that mean
you've never been betrayed by an ex I've
been betrayed by an ex but I I generally
don't I don't think people do evil
things because they're evil I think they
mistake it for happiness I represent
victims of domestic violence and I
represent perpetrators of domestic
violence I represent people who are
married to someone with substance abuse
issues and I represent people who have
substance abuse issues and and you spend
enough time in the room with people and
you start to figure out that like
they're just hurt people hurting people
like they're just trying to figure it
out you know and and maybe they grew up
in a home where violence was acceptable
or and I'm not excusing that behavior I
think there should be consequences for
Behavior without question but if it
explains it it doesn't excuse it but I
still like to understand it so like a
lot of the really Haywire crazy cases
where people violate orders I mean the
craziest case I've ever seen my client
was run over six times by her ex he
tried to kill her while the divorce was
pending and thank God she survived after
many many surgeries and then ended up he
went to jail and he's still in jail be
in jail for the rest of his life for
attempted murder so that's the craziest
one I ever had was that while you were
working on the case yeah yeah why so you
were seeing her all the time and then
randomly she was in the hospital well I
was even more than that I got the call
from her brother saying that this had
happened and they believed it was him
because she had no other enemies and um
oh she was unconscious and everything
she was unconscious for days she was in
the hospital for six months I think she
she was run over six times why does
someone become so self-destructive like
did this guy have a history of abuse
like this he was a perpetrator of
domestic violence intimate partner abuse
yeah but not at such a level like he was
not a guy who was routinely harming her
in that way um I think the the way that
it happened you know I think he lost it
I mean he was he was a pretty crazy guy
to begin with um but I I you know there
was no way to really see that coming see
I I see that kind of thing often that
was an extreme example of it but anger
you know the Daly Lama said that you
know anger is reaching into a pile of
hot coals to throw them at the other
person like you may or may not hit them
but you're going to burn yourself for
sure and this was a guy who was just so
consumed with anger and resentment and
he had pointed all of it at her and I
see that all the time in divorce where
people just blame everything in their
life that they are unhappy about on
their spouse or soon to be former spouse
and I don't think it's rarely honest
it's rarely honest to say this person is
the singular C of all my do you think
that's a coping mechanism that they have
to do that to justify this is a person
that I loved so deeply how could I get
rid of this person let me demonize them
in my head to justify everything that
I'm doing yeah that that makes sense to
me I mean I think that's as good a
theory we're both you know neither of us
is psychologist but that makes sense to
me I mean the only analogy I can give is
when my sons both of my sons when they
were getting ready to go off to college
for that like six months or year before
they went off to college we would get
like much more arguments and they were
much more hostile to me and I remember
saying to their mom like man I don't
know like they they we used to get along
so well and now they're like so kind of
defiant to me and she was like you know
maybe they kind of need to push away so
they can go you know like they they love
you but they're not going to be living
with you anymore they're going off to
college like they got to leave the nest
and to do that they they have to like
dislike you a little you know and when
that was said I thought oh that makes
sense like if you love something so much
you just want to hold it so close to you
always and so I I do think when you're
going to lose something you maybe you
have to to in your head say okay it has
no value it has no value I don't think
it has to be that way I think some
people that's how they process loss you
know like some some people like you're
gonna die I'm gonna die we're all GNA
die I hope that's not like news to you
but you know you can either see that as
something to be terrified of or or as an
invitation to like live your life
because it's the clock is running you
know and I think it's the same thing I
think when you're losing someone you can
either say this person gave me unique
gifts like their their their presence in
my life created certain unique gifts for
me or you can say like oh man my life
without them would have been so many I
would have done all these other things
if I knew it was going to end this way
but I just I just don't think that's
honest what is your background how did
you get into this were you always so
good with people and
negotiation you know I was a Psychology
major in college um I wanted to be a
therapist and then I figured out that
therapists have to listen better than
they talk and I talk better than I
listen so um and I also found out what
they make compared to lawyers now I I uh
I was gonna go into mental health I was
going to be a psychologist I I was
Psychology major with a minor in East
Asian studies and um substance abuse was
the name of the thing whenever I tell
people I minored in substance abuse in
college they was thinking I drank a lot
right um but that was what I was going
to be as either an addiction counselor a
psychologist therapist some kind and
then um I I just ended up I went and got
my Master's Degree at NYU I was teaching
at NYU for a little while I was going to
work on my PhD and then I decided to
take the elsat because uh my then wife
was pregnant with our first child who's
now also an attorney uh and and I said
you know what I did really well on the
outset I got to go to law school for
free and as soon as I went to law school
I said I think I want to be a divorce
lawyer and that was weird if you say to
someone oh you know how did you become a
divorce lawyer they always say well I
ended up it's always got the word ended
up in it which I always thought was
funny because ended up is always like I
made a wrong turn like you never say
like I I ended up in it's like I thought
I was doing this I got drunk and I ended
up in Tiana like it's always it's never
like I meant to do the thing so for me
it was a deliberate Choice like I really
wanted to because it was the best parts
of of what I liked about being a
therapist which was working with people
in a really difficult moment in their
life that they kind kind of couldn't
pretend they meant to be in you know
like no one meant to get divorced yeah
you can't you can you're full of if you
say you know I I intended to get to no
you didn't you intended to stay together
like you consider divorce was a
possibility maybe but you didn't mean to
so I liked that about it and I always
liked speech and debate and
extemporaneous speaking I always had a
performer streak so I always enjoyed
that and being a trial lawyer it's it's
just all the things I love it's it's you
know it's extemporary speaking it's de
bait it's very fast-paced it's never
boring it's I mean I 23 years I've been
doing the same job and I still look
forward to going to work every day but
before we go into that I want to take a
moment and talk about something that's
incredibly important to all of us and
that would be mental well-being so I've
mentioned this before briefly on the
show but I've had ADHD my entire life so
when our sponsor better help reached out
wanting to work with us I was super
excited to try it out I actually signed
up for several different sessions and I
was extremely surprised with how much
they can help with this and how I can
actually leverage my ADHD to now benefit
me rather than beforehand when I felt
like I just couldn't get my thoughts
together it was so easy to use you can
talk to your therapist by text chat
phone or video call and you can even
message your therapist at any time or
schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you better help is the
world's largest therapy service used by
over 4 million people and with 30,000
licensed therapists within their Network
you'll get access to a wide range of
expertise to get helpful unbiased advice
and speaking of someone who's been in
therapy for a couple of years of their
life if you get the wrong therapy IST it
can actually do more harm than help and
fortunately with better help you can
change therapists immediately with no
cost to get started all you do is fill
out a questionnaire to assess your
specific needs and then you'll get
matched with your therapist in most
cases within 48 hours or less so if
you're interested in getting started
with betterhelp click the link Down
Below in the description or visit
betterhelp.com coffee hour to get 10%
off your first month of therapy again
the link is down below in the
description to get 10% off enjoy thank
you so much and now let's get back to
the episode are your parents still
married my mom passed away 8 years ago
but she uh after a long battle with
cancer but they were married for 53
years until she passed away wow and they
had a lovely love story and they had a
lovely life together and um after she
passed away uh my dad remarried a couple
of years later to a very nice woman
who'd lost her husband and who had been
a friend to my mom and my dad and my
dad's in his 80s he's of a generation
where he needed someone to take care of
him and his new spouse is of the
generation where she needed someone to
take care of and so they're a lovely
combination you know and he's very happy
but yeah my parents were married for 53
years what did you learn from your
parents marriage that you wanted to
apply in your marriage or some advice
maybe that you give to some people
you're you know my parents were an
interesting amalgam my dad was a Naval
Academy graduate and a Vietnam veteran
and he was a Reagan conservative and my
mom was a left-wing lunatic like like
almost a Marxist um she was the most
Progressive Li
person you'd ever meet and so I think I
had no choice but to become a lawyer
because I had to see both sides of
everything from infancy you know because
my parents just never voted for the same
people were never on the same side of
any political issue I learned a lot from
that because I knew they were both smart
and good people with good hearts and I
knew they loved each other but they
didn't agree on most political things
and social things but they still
respected and loved each other so I
think I learned a lot about you know
about that you can disagree with someone
and they're not your enemy you know that
you can still love someone and disagree
with their point of view and and um I
also learned a lot because my my mom was
a stay-at-home mom she had been a nurse
and then when my sister and I were born
my sister's six year older than me when
my sister was born she stopped working
and was a stay-at-home mom which of that
generation was a common thing to be and
my dad was a Salesman for a a medical
device company he worked really really
hard but he never ever w said that my
mother didn't work he he was very
mindful of reminding my sister and I
that he and my mother both worked that
he worked outside the home and my mom
worked inside the home and he was always
reminding me like at dinner did you
thank your mother for making this
beautiful dinner for us you know did
like it was it was ingrained in me that
she provided tremendous value and he
provided tremendous value and they were
never counting the cost they were never
I never once heard my father say well I
work so hard you just sit home all day
it was nothing like that and I never
heard her say you know you're always
working you're never they always had
tremendous respect for the role that
each of them played in the family and I
really I think I I got a tremendous
amount out of that would they have those
conversations behind closed doors do you
think or you think they just didn't do
it in front of like I think that they
didn't have those I don't think they had
that resentment I think my father was
very appreciative for the value my
mother brought to our family and my
mother was very you know considered his
value as a provider as a very real thing
I don't think it was insincere at all or
performative I think they really you
know it it translated into my own
relationships like I I really I worked
in restaurants you know all through I I
grew up without money and so I worked in
restaurants all through college and and
part of grad school and you know what
you learn when you work in a restaurant
is like if anybody goes down we're all
going down like so if the hostess isn't
seating properly it's going to have a
ripple effect it's GNA and every we're
all going to be in the weeds so like the
servers the bus boys the chef you know
the the the grill Cooks like if anybody
falls off we're all going down so
there's this tremendous sense of like
hey we all got to support each other as
best we can while doing our individual
job and so I think there's a lot of
value to that I think that that um my
parents saw that very early on that like
hey we all have a role in this family
and we all have to perform our role do
you think people are losing that respect
today it seems like a lot of
grandparents have been together for a
very long time we don't quite see that
to that extent today I don't think
anybody knows how to behave anymore I
think everyone just now feels awful most
of the time I think because I I really
do think there is a a greater Discord
out there I think that you know women
who stay at home are constantly told
well why aren't you a boss babe why
aren't you out in the world making money
are you under your husband's thumb
you're dependent on him and women who
are out in the Working World are like
yeah you're in the Working World you're
making lots of money and you're a girl
boss but what's your home life like and
are you really there for your kids or
they being raised by nannies and are you
really there for your partner like
everyone all the time feels like they're
doing a terrible job because whatever
you're doing there's someone out there
who's going to say yeah but yeah but
what about you know instead of sort of
look there was a problem when everyone
was expected to do the exactly the same
thing women stayed at home and had
babies and men went to work and that was
unfair because there are women who
wanted to be in the workforce and men
who wanted to be home with babies or men
who wanted to pursue creative
Enterprises and things like that so that
was terribly unfair but it certainly
created a c a stability people didn't
have to be so apologetic about the
choices that they make like they they
just felt better in their own skin now
personally I I think what the greater
culture thinks of the dynamic of a
family isn't as important as the two
people in the relationship and so you
know most of the people who end up in my
office are people who have either
convinced themselves or been convinced
by the world that the grass on the other
side of the fence is going to be greener
and and very often you know that's a
side effect of like not just paying
attention to what's going on in their
own house and their own Dynamic if the
two people in the relationship are happy
and they're the best version of
themselves and they're supporting each
other you know I don't think that
Society should have much to do with it
so do you think people are more
influenced today than they were 50 60
years ago well of course I mean how many
people do you interact with now I'm not
talking about interacting with in person
I'm talking about interacting how many
women do you see my father would see
what the women who lived on his street
the women you'd see in church on Sunday
and the women you might run into in the
grocery store yeah you take out your
phone right now scroll through your
Instagram there's 200 women going to
come up on your Instagram either ones
that are absolutely there to show you
their half naked body or ones that are
just sort of in the background or
married to someone you know or whatever
it might be or suggest Ted by the
algorithm you know so yeah we're we're
constantly we're seeing so many other
examples of everyone else's Greatest
Hits while we live our gag reel yeah and
so of course I think that's going to
create a an endless number of
comparisons right and comparison is the
thief of Joy so you're going to spend so
much of your time going wow that guy
looks so much better than me wow that
woman look at the woman he's got and oh
my God look it's constant and again it's
everyone's greatest hits It's a curated
performative look into their life I
can't tell you how many people come into
my office for a consultation and then I
look at their social media and their
social media is you know hash blessed
like they're greatest husband ever you
know hash best wife ever I'm like you
you're sleeping with three different
people I know CU you just told me it in
my office but you're not going to put
that on your Instagram you know you're
not going to tell me that yeah on our
last vacation like we got in a screaming
fight and he broke a lamp at the resort
when he threw it at me no no there's
great photos from that vacation that
vacation was wonderful if you look at
social media so if you're comparing your
vacation with your significant other to
that vacation the social media version
of it your vacation sucked but it didn't
show the throw I was thinking so much is
reading other people's thoughts that
it's a lot easier to go on Reddit let's
just say and post something and get
hundreds or thousands of different
perspectives whereas 60 years ago it
would just be your circle of influence
who knows you in your specific situation
knows who you are as a person what's
important to you maybe it could give you
more tailored advice than someone just
commenting something but advice just
falls out of the sky now too doesn't it
I mean I I I think having a defined
sense of self was easier because it was
clearer what was expected of you like
like I don't think my father ever really
sat around and went I wonder if I'm a
good father like I wonder how I'm doing
this if am I meeting my child's
emotional needs like I don't think that
ever crossed his mind he's like my job
is to get keep the bills paid and the
lights on and make sure you have clothes
and food like that was his role so
anything he did other than that was
extra if he went fishing with me it was
like now I'm like the gold standard dad
you know but even like I have friends
who are fathers in this modern sort of
zist and they're jumping from one foot
to the other and they still feel like
failures because it's like well yeah you
this but you didn't take them to this
well you took them to that but you did
you spend the whole day and you're like
oh my god really like what do you expect
of people so I I think a lot of the time
now we all feel like we could be doing
much better and we were not working hard
enough at our relationship at our job at
our side hustle at our paren and
whatever it might be but the truth is
like we're comparing ourselves to such
ideals as opposed to the people actually
around us like I I never felt as
handsome as when I went to Disney World
I took my kids to Disney World you know
I live in Manhattan so when you live in
Manhattan there's just gorgeous people
everywhere like it's unbelievable so I I
live in ch I live in West Chelsea so I
live in a primarily gay neighborhood so
some of the gay men of Chelsea they look
look photoshopped like this is the best
looking men I've ever seen in my life
and I'm in the elevator with them and
I'm like cuz they just compare to these
guys I you forget it AB oh six ABS
chisel just gorgeous like they're just
yeah perfect hair they have a skin
regimen because unlike heterosexual men
who are like you know like I want to
talk about my skincare regimen they're
like hey we're not bound by these strict
gender roles we can talk about this
stuff so I really am you know but you go
to Disney World and you're like oh this
is America you know and like hey I'm not
everyone's thought it though that's the
thing it's a true listen man there's
people in in Disney World going around
on those jazzes because they're so obese
that they can't walk around and I'm not
saying those people are terrible people
I I I'm just simply saying compared to
if you hang out in a room full of
supermodels you're going to feel bad
about how you look you know so if you
want to feel skinny hang out with
overweight people you know if you want
to feel fit you know so I I really think
that that is a little bit of this is
that people are now comparing themselves
to a giant pool
of performative relationships as opposed
to looking at their relationship
compared to their friend right like look
when you're in a relationship how much
sex is a good amount of sex none of us
know yeah none of us know like your
friends don't how many friends really
sit around and say even your closest
friends how many of them really tell you
how many times a week they have sex and
who initiates it and are they doing like
all kinds of stuff or do they just do
like the straightup act or is it like
like how often do you have oral sex how
often do you no one's going to talk
about and to the extent that they do are
they really being honest about it so
what are you comparing it to right and
and we're we're it's so natural to want
to compare to other people but we didn't
have anything to compare it to for so
long now we compare it to this idealized
image of things when really the answer
is are you happy do you feel satisfied
does your partner feel satisfied great
that's all that matters doesn't matter
keep your eyes on your plate it doesn't
matter what everybody else is doing you
know I always say that when it comes to
money it's like listen it where you are
at financially guarantee there are bet I
have clients worth hundreds of millions
of dollars who are jealous of my clients
who are worth billions of dollars okay
now they already both have more money
than they or their grandchildren will
ever need but if that's the metric by
which you're measuring your success
there's always somebody who's going to
be richer there's always going to be
somebody who's richer and younger or the
same rich but younger so they can enjoy
it more like come on you know so if you
can get a sense of there's only two
amounts of money enough and not enough
that's it there's only two amounts of
sex enough or not enough so that's
really up to the two people in the
relationship I'm so sorry we had to cut
in right here but this next part is
going to blow your mind but you know
what blew my mind I have to say is I
just learned that you could build credit
with a debit card and historically that
has never been the case it's incredible
like here's the thing with old school
Banks it just isn't working anymore
you're always dinged with ridiculous
fees it takes credit to get credits
there's minimum account B it's a big
hassle so stop banking old and get with
their sponsor current current is banking
and credit building bundled into one
through a very simple and Seamless app
where you can get paid build credit and
save all in the same place when you set
up direct deposit on current you could
get paid up to two days faster qualify
for fee-free overdraft up to $200 and
you could build credit safely using your
own money with the build card with
current there are no credit checks so
you could start building your credit at
any time and quite possibly the best
part about current is that there's no
annual fees and no minimum balance fees
so if you want to step into the future
of banking go to current.com iedc coffee
hour or download the app you could also
earn $50 by setting up direct deposit
again with the code iced coffee hour of
course terms apply again it's
current.com coffee hour join the future
of banking and start building credit
with a debit card thank you so much
current and back to the show so why is
it do you think that most relationships
fail I I think they fail because people
stop paying attention and people stop
being grateful you know I think I think
the best way to look at why things end
is to look at how they started and and
and when a relationship starts there's
this tremendous period of like paying
attention to each other and trying to to
impress each other with how much you're
paying attention and how much you care
about each other and how much you're
you're noticing the other person and
there's also a tremendous sense of like
overlooking the flaws of someone right
or even finding them Charming you know
when when somebody has like a snort to
their laugh you know it's like oh she's
so cute she has a little snort to her
laugh whereas you know you're together
for a bunch of years and it's like what
is this snort what was that you know so
you start to really and I don't
understand really why we do that in
romantic relationships because we don't
do it in other kinds of relationships
when you've had your kid for five years
you don't go like this freaking kid like
I got to get a new one you know or you
don't have like a dog like anybody who's
a dog owner like if you have your dog
for 10 years you're not like oh I've had
this dog I got to get a puppy man
they're so much cuter and fuzzier you
know like you go oh my God it's my dog
like I've had it for 10 years I love
that song relationships were very quick
to just stop being grateful for the
value the person brings to our life
we're very quick to stop noticing that
they're even there and that they're what
they're there for and then we stop being
kind to each other we stop being
attentive to each other and I I think
relationships are all about little
things I think it's all about little
courtesies and little compliments and
little ways of like if you talk to most
people about their love
life they will remember giant things
like when we went on this vacation or
when we had this candle lit dinner on
the beach these dramatic gestures
because those are super interesting
stories but really love is like little
day-to-day things you know it's just
like Finance like Finance is not you
know yeah there's is they're the person
that bought this crypto at this price
and then suddenly they're a billionaire
sure but that's the exception not the
rule most of the time it's just a grind
and a grind and a grind first million's
the hardest and then once you got that
if you're smart about it and disciplined
as an investor you're going to be fine
you do really well but it's not sexy
it's not sexy like you know everybody
wants like the Crypt billionaire story
but they don't want to hear they're like
oh yeah municipal bonds might make sense
for you for a certain percentage of your
portfolio from a tax place like nobody
wants to hear that they want to hear the
like yeah this stock was 10 cents and
now it's $50 so I think it's this same
thing with relationships like we those
little boring pieces of advice I could
give you tell your partner how much you
value them tell them how beautiful they
are to you tell them you know what
things you're thankful for in them you
know why why not like what what do you
what is that cost yeah do you think this
is just romantic relationships or also
friendships all relationships I think
it's human Rel Rel these are human
relationships I mean I think there's
different things you convey to a
romantic partner you know it should be
easier with a romantic partner because a
romantic partner there's so many other
spheres of connection like a spouse is
your roommate maybe your co-parent or
your pet co-parent they're your travel
companion they're your sleeping
companion like so that's a much larger
field of things to feel like they're
getting wrong but it's also a much
larger field of things to be grateful
for you know deeply grateful for and to
express that gratitude for you know and
I I do genuinely look there are people
that are not meant to be together I've
been a divorce lawyer for 23 years and
I'm divorced myself I believe in divorce
I think there are people that with good
intentions and good faith tried to make
it work and they realize you know what
we are not bringing out the best in each
other and there might be someone else
who would be able to do that for us do
you ever see or can tell instantly these
two people aren't going to be together
in a relationship yeah yeah I can I can
I got a pretty good radar for that and
what do you notice in that like I the
way I honed that skill was watching The
Real Housewife shows on Bravo I used to
watch those shows on Bravo
watch the first season of each of them
and i' go they're getting divorced
they're getting divorced and they're
getting divorced What specifically
stands out it was the way they talked to
each other and it was also the way that
they talk about each other when the
other one's not there those were two
things that stand out I I have to tell
you I genuinely believe that if you are
not the cheerleader and fan of your
partner that you're you're not that far
away from the ruin of that relationship
like there are 8 billion people in the
world and you picked this person as the
one you're going to have the most
intimate relationship with if you can't
have kind words for them the majority of
the time whether to them or to third
parties talking about them you made a
You made a wrong choice so do you think
that's a sign of maybe disrespect for
the other person I think it's disrespect
I think it's also just the lack of
affection and gratitude for that person
and their role in your life I mean it's
a glass half full half empty kind of a
thing like this this person look we're
human we're flawed we're all all flawed
and I don't want a partner who doesn't
know that I'm flawed I want a partner
who knows I'm flawed and loves me and
loves my flaws and sees my flaws as as a
sign of my humanity and weakness that's
also in them that they have humanity and
weakness in them but they also have
tremendous Beauty and power and strength
in them so I I want a partner who
inspires the best in me and I Inspire
the best in them and when I fall they
don't stand there and go look you fell I
knew you were going to fall they say
like all right yeah you fell hey man
people fall come on let's get up let's
get up or they just are kind and they
just say hey you fell that looks like it
hurt you okay like because the rest of
the world will be real quick to point
out when you fell and real quick to just
cheer for the fact that you fell or to
say like I didn't fall he fell but I
didn't fall like so to have a partner
who's there for all those potential
possibilities but look you know again if
your partner isn't the one who's
cheering for you and trying to help and
trying to prevent you from falling or
helping you one once you fall you know I
don't I don't think that there's
anything Noble in staying miserable
together why do you think it is that
most of the people that initiate
divorces are women you know I get so
many questions about that statistic and
I see in like the red pill space and the
manosphere people who I really like and
respect like Rolo and and Mike like
these are all like bright people in the
sort of manosphere space who I I I they
quote that statistic and I know how
people take it and that is that they're
like oh women are just get married and
then they kind of cash out because
divorce is so favorable to women and
then that's it you know women are just
so they're never happy they're never
satisfied and that's why they're getting
divorced and they instigate the divorces
I I I have not seen that to be my
experience as a divorce lawyer for 23
years having handled thousands of
divorces what I find is there are a lot
of men and women who initiate divorce
right but but the question is is that's
who files for divorce right that's who
files the papers so I have lots of women
who filed for divorce the husband left
started sleeping with someone else
barely visits the kids or doesn't pay
any child support and they come to my
office and they go hey how do I you know
like like he moved out six months ago
and he was paying and then he stopped
paying and now he's dating and I go we
have to file a divorce action and they
go well but I don't want to do that
because I really hope it'll still work
out and z i go we have to file we can't
get a judge assigned to a case that
doesn't exist we have to file for
divorce so we file a divorce action now
you tell me is it her fault they're
getting divorced no she just was willing
to pay the $385 filing fee and he just
went out for milk and never came back so
I'm not I don't think those statistics
say what they I'm not suggesting there's
not something to look at in the plight
of modern men and modern women and how
they relate to each other and how
favorable divorce is to women versus men
and how the traditional role of women is
protected by you know is not protected
by the state in divorce but the
traditional role of men is so you know
if we're married and you're being nice
to me and sleeping with me and I'm
paying your bills and protecting you if
we get divorced the state can enforce my
end of that bargain where I have to
continue to provide for you financially
but they can't enforce the obligation
for you to be nice to me or have sex
with me so I there's a conversation to
be had about men and women and who
initiates divorce and bl but it's not
who files for divorce that tells
anything about what's going on in male
female relationships that's just who
who's willing to do the paperwork that's
what I was telling Jack about in the car
I thought it was who's more culpable of
that divorce and if women are the ones
initiating are men the ones who are
doing things in the relationship to
cause the women to file for divorce
right think and I think that is
something you will never be able to
study because the truth is at the bottom
of a bottomless pit like if you ask
people who's to blame for the marriage
you you'll be shocked to hear most
people are the hero of Their Own Story
if you ask them and the other side's the
villain but but you talk to enough
people and you go yeah like this is a
marriage like there's two sides to it
and sometimes it's really obvious like
oh yeah he's sleeping with his secretary
okay he's sleeping you haven't slept
with him in four years what was he
supposed to do was he supposed to just
divorce you you got kids together he
didn't want to do that you know so yeah
he's human he took the bait he slept
with somebody else I'm not saying that's
morally acceptable but you can't say
it's his fault we getting divorced cuz
he slept with his secretary okay but but
wait a minute that's that's a symptom of
a greater problem and that is that the
two of you disconnected at some point
you know you didn't have the
relationship either of you intended to
have so you know whose fault is that so
I don't think who files more is all that
instructive about anything I get it that
it makes for like a really easy thing to
point to but all of these people now
talking about no like I'm hearing in
like the very traditional you know in
the tradcon world everyone's like we got
to get rid of no fa divorce we got to
get as if getting rid of no fa divorce
would somehow magically make people be
happily married or not get the that's
like saying we got to get rid of all
these emergency rooms because there's so
many these sick people go into this
place and if you just got rid of those
emergency let's get rid of homeless
shelters because that'll get rid of all
these stupid homeless people you know
it's just creating the opportunity for
people to just go to homeless shelters
like it's stupid that makes no sense no
fault divorce all that it did was took
money out of my pocket as a divorce
lawyer because divorce when it's
fault-based you have to prove fault so
we used to do fault trials and it was
great I made an extra 10 $20,000 to
prove why someone was to blame in this
divorce which by the way what does it
matter do you think forcing if one
person wants to get divorced in the
marriage do you think forcing the that
person to stay married to the other
person is going to benefit that family
that person or our society one bit it's
not you want make barriers to entry of
marriage if you want to protect marriage
make barriers to entry not exit right
make barriers to if you want to get
married you got to take a class or you
got to have a waiting period like you do
with a gun or you have to like there
there make barriers to entry not
barriers to exit but before we go into
that as I'm sure you've seen behind
every business is an inspiring success
story and if you're ready to start
writing one of your own there's not a
better place to start than with our
sponsor Shopify Shopify is the global
e-commerce platform that's already
helped grow millions of businesses
worldwide for example Shopify is an
endless list of Integrations thirdparty
apps and flexible templates to customize
your online store exactly the way you
want it what really set Shopify apart
from its competitors is its ability to
turn browsers into buyers with the
internet's best converting checkout and
remember gram that's 36% better on
average compared to other leading
e-commerce platforms funny you mention
that Jack because Shopify also Powers
10% of all e-commerce in the United
States how much of that 10% % is
bankroll coffee well it's funny you
mention that because bankroll coffee my
coffee company has been run through
Shopify since its Inception and we did a
lot of research on the best platform to
use and they consistently came up the
best and they've been absolutely
fantastic I wouldn't even consider
anything else because Shopify is that
good so sign up for a $1 per month trial
period at shopify.com
all lowercase all lowercase all lower
case again that's shopify.com to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're in shopify.com $1 per month trial
period thank you so much Shopify and
back to the episode for someone who's
getting married what is your
recommendation for those barriers to
have the highest chance of success know
what you're doing know what you're doing
ask why you're getting married what is
the problem to which marriage is a
solution because you're already in love
right you're already with this person
you're already you know the unless you
are someone who's from a religious
community that okay we can't have sex
unless we get married okay if you're
already having a physical relationship
you're already having you know emotional
relationship with this person you're
already monogamous with this per okay
you already have a lot of those things
so what is it that you're doing is it
the legal benefits of marriage most
people it's not they couldn't even tell
you what the legal benefits of marriage
are so if if I gave you like a multiple
choice quiz you couldn't you'd probably
get a 50 on it you know if even so
really what it is is you want to tell
the world something about your
relationship that's what I think most
people are getting married it's a public
declaration
of we are the person's other like
because it's a different thing if I say
this is my girlfriend all right could be
my girlfriend for a week what is that
but if I go this is my wife you go okay
take that seriously you know if I'm your
boss and I say this is my girlfriend you
be like she might not be around in a
week she might be like the goldfish that
you know in a week she'll be Belly Up in
the in the bowl you know but a wife it's
like hey you know a wife's somebody
that's got status you know I get hit by
a car she gets to come into the hospital
room you know so that that's what most
people are looking for when they marry
the problem is the state imposes a
tremendous amount of legal rights and
obligations on the relationship of
marriage and most people don't even know
what that is so my advice to a person
who is engaged is a understand why
you're getting engaged you personally
and why is your partner getting engaged
like why is your fiance interested in
getting engaged to you why do she want
to get married and see if those
interests align or if they're in
contrast to each other do you think this
is going to change the nature of your
relationship that you'll take each other
more seriously like oh he's cheating on
me while we're boyfriend and girlfriend
but once we're married he won't anymore
like that's naive you know so ask
yourself why are we doing this educate
yourself as to what are the legal
implications of it that's why I like
people who do prenups because prenups
force people to have
conversations about a difficult but real
thing that I think is an invitation into
talking about some of the most important
things in a relationship for it to be
successful yeah why does the state put
so many limitations on marriage why do
they do that what's the point someone's
let's let's say together for 20 years as
boyfriend girlfriend versus someone who
has met each other for you know a few
weeks and signs a paper what's the
difference between that why does it
sayate say one is more important than
the other you know I think the state
designs laws based on the most
irresponsible people right like if you
wanted to be honest about the sign on
the
highway it should say drive as fast as
you feel comfortable based on the
weather conditions the flow of traffic
and your abilities as a driver but
that's a a very long sign and B a
totally subjective standard so what does
it say 65 miles an hour is 64 safer no
maybe not is 66 more dangerous probably
not right are you g to get pulled over
if you do 70 probably not right but we
just got to pick a number so that's the
number that we pick so I think all of
our laws around marriage are designed
for specific purposes but they're
designed for Bad actors really they're
designed for people who would not in
good faith like like in theoretically we
shouldn't need child support laws
because people would just be like hey
it's my kid I'm going to support my kid
of course you know but there's
tremendous variability in what someone
might want for child support what
someone might need for child support
what someone might be willing to pay for
the support of their children and it
could be a tremendously fraught conflict
f things so what do we do 177% for one
child 25% for two children 29% for three
children 31% for four children is that
the right number I don't know you know
is 65 miles an hour the right number for
the highway no it's just a number it's
just the number that they put together
in they picked so it's designed
theoretically to protect against Bad
actors and to make sure that we can
function as a stable Society so those
numbers that you just gave that's a
percentage of your income that's going
to the to your ex spouse for child for
how often is it that that money actually
goes to the kids there's really no way
to know because you're not paying it to
the kids you're paying it to your ex so
I I've had a lot of clients grapple with
that question I've had clients who call
me up and go I am paying $5,000 a month
in child support and my kids are telling
me there's no food in the fridge but
she's driving a Mercedes like what's
going on or she's on vacation in you
know the Bahamas with her boyfriend and
my kids are saying there's no food in
the fridge um and the truth is that yeah
I mean there's nobody going to police
that necessarily if it happens
consistently enough you can go back to
court and try to argue that it's not
being used for the benefit of the kids
but it's a rare thing to be able to
prove and if the man of the house let's
just say is making like $3 million a
year then 30% of that if he has a few
kids like he's going to give away a
million doar there yeah so there's caps
yeah there's caps there's a presumptive
statutory cap but there's a certain
amount of discretion judges can do the
highest child support award I've ever
had in a case is I had a client who I
got $35,000 a month for and and that
that was a family though that was you
know they were high-profile they had
security they had a lot of things that
you know when you live a a celebrity
lifestyle or a ultra high net worth
lifestyle you know there's different
considerations you have to think about
security you have to think about
kidnapping risk you have to think about
all those kinds of things so it's very
much tied to the lifestyle of the
children when you get to those higher
numbers but the presumptive statutory
cap is in the couple of hundred, range
generally what's the biggest alimony
you've ever settled the highest I've
ever had on a monthly basis was 75,000
on a monthly basis for a period of I
think eight years I've seen some lumpsum
buyouts of spousal support where a
person was given like five or 10 million
in L A good rule of thumb is like a
third of your gross income for a third
of the duration of the marriage so if
you were married for yeah if you were
married for nine years maybe three years
of alimony roughly and if you make a
hundred grand a year maybe you're going
to pay like 20 $330,000 and what's the
biggest difference in wealth between the
partners that you saw like the most
maybe maybe unfair you were telling a
unconscionable but not that but just un
there tons of unfair I mean but look at
what ATT tracks I mean you know it's
it's rare that like a hedge fund manager
marries another hedge fund manager you
know usually a hedge fund manager
marries a yoga teacher or a model you
know so what does she make you know she
makes nothing you know she makes you
know 20 grand a year and he makes you
know 10 million so it's common for there
to be tremendous disparities in wealth
in in a couple and the question really
is you know you're not going to when you
divorce someone you're not going to have
all the benefits of the marriage anymore
like I've had clients who say to me you
know like well I'm not gonna be able to
fly private anymore and you're like
right and he's not going to get to sleep
with you anymore like there's some perks
to being married to each other that go
away but the the job of the court system
in theory is to make sure you know
there's there's what you need there's
what you want and there's what you're
entitled to what you need you're going
to get you need food you need shelter
you need to be able to like live your
life what you want there could be no
limit to what you might want so what you
want is informed by what you're entitled
to so the law is supposed to create
something that is approximately fair for
the for the all the totality of the
circumstances now you were mentioning
earlier that people with prenups tend
not to get divorced at the same rate as
people with prup that's been my
experience what's the reason for that
you know again that's there's no
statistics on this because there is no
where you have to register a prenup so
like prenups just get put in a safe
somewhere like they're not filed with
the county clerk they're just put aside
like the couple the bride keeps one the
groom keeps one and then their lawyers
keep one and that's it so it's not filed
anywhere so I can tell you like having
done I probably do a dozen prenups a
month and a lot of those people like
some of them celebrities in public they
will talk about oh we got married we
don't have a prenup they do I know I
wrote it it's in my safe I can't show it
to anybody but I know I know they have a
prenup because I wrote their prenup and
I watched them both sign it so when they
go out and say oh no we would never we
have faith in our love we didn't do a
prenup you're lying it's fine you have a
right to lie you have confidentiality
you're allowed to lie but you're sending
the wrong message you're sending the
wrong message to the world because it
would be better I would be more
impressed if you said like yeah we have
a prup like we're pragmatic about it we
have every confidence we're never going
to need it but you know we did it of
course like I don't want to die tomorrow
but I have life insurance you know like
I don't I don't I I drive my car safely
but I have airbags you know it's good
you know so I think people who have a
prenup it's proof no matter what it's
proof that you you have the ability to
have a difficult conversation you have
the ability to talk pragmatically and
realistically about the fact that this
love is on loan it's not owned it's not
permanently deed to either of you it's
on loan and all marriages end all of
them they end in death or they end in
divorce it's one of those weird things
that you go I really hope this ends in
death you know like it's very few other
things in life you say that about I have
found and I've now done hundreds if not
thousands of prenups over my career that
I've only had a small number of people
that then move forward with a divorce
action because I I think the kind of
people that can have honest pragmatic
conversations about but what if like I
hope it doesn't happen but what if
and that those are the kind of people
that can have hard conversations what is
a prenup but being proactive what is a
prenup but having you know trading what
you want now for what you want most and
and and and by the way I think a prenup
is an act of love I don't want my
partner to be with me because they're
afraid to get divorced like getting
divorce sucks sucks it's unpleasant even
the friendliest divorce it's unpleasant
you know but you don't want someone to
stay with you because they're afraid of
getting divorced from you you want
someone to stay with you because they
like being with you they're happy being
with you that you bring value to their
life and they bring it to yours so a
prenup is a way to say like hey if we
split up you're okay you'll be okay I've
always felt exactly that but other
people without prup say it's it's a
barrier to getting divorced if we have
to sell the house if we have to go
through with the expense of finding and
splitting everything down the middle
it's one more step that we have to work
through that's almost a bit of a barrier
to get divorce is a not having a prenup
so we've talked to people who say
incentive yeah yeah exactly that they
say Hey by not having a prenup it forces
us it puts a bit of a stopper on this a
bit of a gap in between us not wanting
to that's the assumption that most
people can make it work yeah that's the
craziest thing I I just that makes no
sense I understand it from a logic
selling a stock from your phone by
clicking sell or calling up someone on
the phone want to buy a stock it's a bit
of a so you know what I let's let's take
that logic a little further yeah so why
don't we have penalty Clauses where
we're getting married but if you cheat
on me I get half of what's in your bank
account even if we stay married like why
don't are we what are we doing we're
betting now like we're creating barriers
like oh I want because I have to tell
you man I I the idea of someone staying
with you because it's going to be more
unpleasant to get divorced like that
does not seem appealing to me like you
didn't marry each other because it was
easy like you didn't go like oh this was
e like it's you know like make barriers
to entry then like what I mean it just
seems so bizarre to me like to why not
have like a you know why not do like
that Fear Factor show you want to
divorce me you have to eat these bull
testicles you know let's see how much
you really want to divorce me that seems
silly to me like look if you're with me
you want to be with me I want to be with
you like this is about if this marriage
ends do either of us feel terribly taken
advantage of will either of us crawl out
of this marriage rather than walk out of
it like I I don't want some I don't want
a woman to be with me because she's like
where am I going to live if we break up
don't what am I in I'm an apartment like
you chose me for that that's insane you
know that's like me saying to to a woman
like well you break a nail I'm out of
here you know like I'm here because
you're hot you know like if you leave
forget it you get less hot I'm out like
that's that's insane I would be
horrified if if if if if I said that to
a woman so I really don't I think that
there is a wonderful denial that people
in love want to do I get it like I get
it I understand people don't want to go
like I have lots of friends who don't
want to get a physical why don't you
want to get a physical because I don't
want to hear the doctor's going to say I
got to do this okay so you'd rather wait
until you're super sick at some point
because there was something preventable
that you could have got checked out on
like that makes no sense to me same
thing with the prenups so why do you
think PRI prenups are so frowned upon it
seems like it's it's almost as though
you don't believe in the relationship so
you gotta prenup right well that that is
the popular perception which is why is
that
you know it's a great question I think a
piece of it is probably that people who
don't have prenups want to convince
themselves that it was a shrewd decision
that they don't have one you know like
they don't want to be like yeah it was
stupid I wish I had one like most of the
you only have one shot at doing a prenup
the day you get married it's no longer a
prenup it's a postnup if anything so
most people who don't have prenups they
don't want to go yeah I'm an idiot you
know like they want to say oh well yeah
there was here's why I didn't have that
prenup it's I don't we have more faith
in each other than that like okay
there's a 56% chance you're getting
divorced but cool yeah that's a great
gamble like you know that's that's
insane so I I don't I think we
justify that lack of prenups because a
lot of people don't have prenups prenups
are I will tell you having done this for
over 20 years the last three four years
prenups are much more common it is much
l again we're still not at a place where
people talk openly about it and I think
that's for the reason you said which is
people feel like it's you don't have
faith in the marriage it must be that
you don't have faith in each other but I
I'm telling you behind closed doors
particularly the generation that's in
their 20s and 30s now that's getting
married prenups up the Wazoo we're doing
so I had I think I did seven prenup
consults last week this past week how
effective are prenups in court do they
hold up pretty firmly yeah very very
because I feel like I've heard so many
stories about people who like they get
the prenup signed and then for some
reason it doesn't hold up in court or is
that something that was done wrong with
the documentation necessarily the two
answers to that one is that sometimes
people are full of it right they're just
lying okay um but but I think sometimes
like I think some of that's like Urban
mythology like well I know I got a
friend everyone's got a friend who has a
cousin who knows the guy who's prenup
didn't in stand up and you go okay who
who is this because I'm a divorce lawyer
for 20-some years and I I I I've seen
some prenups enforced that I was like
how could they enforce that it's so
unfair I mean I had a prenup upheld in
New York state supreme court that was 24
years ago while my client was 6 months
pregnant standing in the vestibule of
the church with 150 people inside the
church he handed it to her for the first
time in the vestibule of the church
while she's six months pregnant wearing
her white wedding dress and he said if
you don't sign this I'm not coming down
that aisle with you and the court 24
years later upheld that prenup no that
to me seems like an extreme how did they
uphold that to me that seems like she's
under duress being pregnant
maybe fearing what's gonna happen if I
have a child and having 10050 dur duress
has a very specific legal definition and
it's a high burden for a good reason
because contracts sometimes in
retrospect you go man I shouldn't have
sign that but the question is is at the
time was it a fair contract and you know
was it distasteful did the court
probably feel good about upholding that
contract no but their attitude was
listen you could have said no you could
have said no it's not like you wouldn't
be pregnant anymore it's not like you
know yeah you he may maybe he would have
called his bluff he would have said all
right we'll Doin It Anyway his family
was in there too you know but you the
they are upheld are there some that
don't get upheld sure you want to go on
you know a website and download a PR
everybody's got Google now everybody's
like oh I'm not going to spend $2,000 on
a prenup I can Google it I can get a
Word document oh this what this place
will give you one for $50 and yeah they
screw up some piece of the drafting of
it or it's just a boiler plate that
doesn't have some of the state specific
things that should have like so those
get set aside they get set aside and
there's other reasons why prenups get
set aside like if a lot of times people
marry people who English isn't their
first language so if that person doesn't
understand English sufficiently to know
the contract that they signed I've seen
prenup set aside for that reason again
there's ways to control for that like
when I do a prup for someone who they
they're soon to be spouse was raised in
a different country I have a a certified
translation done of either the entire
agreement or of a provision that says
that even though this person does not
they acknowledge English isn't their
native language that they've had a
translate they understand English
sufficiently and I make sure that that's
translated that paragraph into their
native language so no one can so there's
like lawyers can solve four problems but
if you're just trusting Google to like
give you your advice yeah you're going
to get and and people talk about prenups
that got set aside that's why people
think divorces are all horrible and ugly
because you know who talks about their
divorce people who were wounded by it
like my divorce was the least
interesting thing you know when I when I
go to a I don't go to cocktail parties
but when I do occasionally go to a
social event people go what do you do
for a living I said I'm a divorce lawyer
they go oh my God you must have such
stories and if I said yeah like I got
this one case where these two people
fell in love where they were in college
because they both found each other
really attractive and then they got
married and then after a certain period
of time they realized they had really
different value systems and they
realized that they weren't really a good
match for each other and so they decided
that you know they should probably end
the marriage and try to find better
Partners so they respectfully divided
their ass
assets he would be like that's the
stupidest story ever like that's not
what I wanted oh no you want to hear
about yeah so then he took a chain saw
and he cut the bed in half and he said
you can have the left half or the right
half because that's half is yours like
they want that story so people who've
had horrible divorces who've been
wounded by it they talk about their
divorce all the time so then you start
to go oh yeah divorces man they're
horrible I heard the story about it
right but you didn't hear about the tons
of people that get divorced that they're
like yeah it didn't work out but you
know she's one of one of the great loves
of my life great person good parent you
know we still get along what percentage
are like that though the majority of
divorces are boring okay the majority of
divorces are accounting problems like
they really are about who gets what and
how do we divide it and what's the right
numbers it's not knock down drag out
trying to kill each other but are the
other ones way more interesting totally
a a a boring divorce like a typical
divorce you know figure out what we have
and cut it in half 20 grand 30 Grand in
legal fees a knockdown drag out divorce
I can get a month in in one of those
cases I can do 203 Grand you make
millions as a lawyer on ugly horrible
knockdown drag out divorces but the
overwhelming majority of divorces
they're not like that they're actually
somewhat just civil transactions do
lawyers have an incentive to sometimes
make it worse than it actually is like
let's say you're representing someone
say you know what no you should get more
you deserve this of course yeah there's
a tremendous incentive for that in a
practical standpoint but very few
lawyers who do that last in this
business or ever develop you live and
die by your reputation in this business
and if you're that kind of lawyer word
gets out that you're that kind of lawyer
and and and and it hurts your business
people won't refer people to you people
hate having you as an adversary judges
start to figure out that you're just
that kind of person who's obstructionist
and unnecessarily you know obstreperous
in the way that you handle cases like
that's not but yes of course there's
trem by the way I leverage that
incentive all the ton because I say to
my clients like listen I think we're
within the parameter to settle this case
and they go well yeah but I want this
and I go you understand I get paid to
fight that fight for you so if I'm
trying to talk you out of that fight I
must be telling you the truth because if
we fight that fight I'm going to make a
lot of money whether I win or lose like
you know I'm not a personal injury
personal injury lawyers if I get you a
recovery I get to keep a third of it
divorce lawyers I win I keep the money I
lose I keep the money so a divorce
lawyer saying to you no no settle on
that issue but no let's fight the fight
on that issue we have tremendous
Financial incentive to encourage people
to fight but very very rarely have I
seen that in I I don't see it in myself
I've rarely seen it in my colleagues
because you just will not make it in
this business if you do that so if
you're getting divorced without a prenup
how does that conversation usually go in
the courtroom how do the assets usually
get divided and I heard you mentioned
before something of the tune of good
spouse bonus and bad spouse penalties
and somehow they they did away with that
but to me I feel like that sounds fair
to consider who was the bad actor in
this situation how could we make that
even yeah so so it's two different
questions you asked but but the second
one I'll take first and that is yeah I
always tell people there is no good
spouse bonus and there's no bad spouse
penalty and a lot of times people are
disheartened to hear that mostly the bad
spouse penalty part not the good spouse
Bon
because you have two good spouses that's
like who gets the bonus but yeah bad
spouse penalty people very often are
like wait what do you mean the fact that
she cheated on me with four different
people doesn't change what she's
entitled to it should the problem is
what I said the earlier which is okay
but why was she cheating on you like
what was going on there like if you ask
her it's that you were never satisfying
her needs you were really discourteous
to her you made her feel unloved she
went into the arms of somebody else's a
function of it if you ask him it's that
she's just a you know and that she
ran off with somebody El like so the
truth is again kind of at the bottom of
a bottomless pit and think about how do
you prove it like look at a relationship
you've had that broke up who how do you
in a court of law if you had to prove
that you were the good guy in that
relationship how do you do it bring
Witnesses Who Your Friends guess what
I'll tell you right now your friends are
going to say you did it right and she
did it wrong her friends they're gonna
have the opposite story they're gonna
say like my mom if you put her on the
stand under cross-examination she'll
still say I'm the handsomest boy in the
whole wide world does doesn't mean it's
true just means my mom loves me you know
so it's the same thing like it's your
you really you don't want the legal
system deciding who was good at being
married and who was bad at being married
and and and what the incentives were you
know because again like he neglected my
needs I'm sorry I was working three jobs
I neglected your needs no I would rather
have been home meeting your needs but I
was working my second job you know so
there's so many and again I don't know
who's right and who's wrong and I don't
know that a person in a black robe with
a law degree would be better at making
that decision that there would then be a
financial penalty you know so I I get
how in theory you know in in theory
communism is a great idea everybody will
just according to their take according
to their need and give according to
their means like it's great in practice
it leaves the trail of blood and it's a
short line to the gulag you know whereas
in in theory it makes a lot of sense
like the perfect society would be an
ordered Anarchy where everybody does the
right thing because it's the right thing
to do and because they have a moral okay
that's fairy tales gang that's not real
real is look in we if if a relationship
ends and that's your other question when
a relationship ends if there wasn't a
prenup what do we do it's easy
identification valuation distribution so
we identify what the assets are what do
we have how big is the pie valuation
what's it worth if it's a house get it
appraised if it's a bank account what's
the the value how does it fluctuate what
went in what went out what did you have
before you got married what did you have
during the marriage how did it
appreciate and depreciate and then three
distribution and what's that horse
trading all right well I'll keep because
what would you I mean if divorce was
when you get divorced we just sell
everything you own and split the
proceeds like I guess that's one way to
do it it's a stupid way to do it instead
you go well look I'm I want to stay in
the house okay well I'll buy you out of
the house well I'm entitled a part of
your 401k so why don't you keep your
whole 401k and I'll keep the house right
but dollars aren't the same like it's
apples and oranges because deferred
assets is value okay so let's do a
present value analysis of that great and
that's what lawyers do at our best I've
had ultra high net worth clients who
come in and say yeah we're splitting up
we don't have a prenup figure out what I
have and give her half great it takes me
and six other lawyers six months to
figure out what they have and how to
divide it in half because there's tax
impacting there's depreciation there's
all kinds of things to think about so
you know ultimately whether it's the
simplest of divorces with a small
marital estate like I'm in a sense I'm a
little like a mortician you know like
the body of a president and the body of
a homeless person it's just a body it's
just meat it's just the circulatory
system respiratory system all those
whether I'm dividing you know a cop and
a teacher with a 401k in a house with a
little bit of equity and some credit
card debt or whether I'm helping someone
divide you know the eight homes that
they own in hundreds of millions of
dollars it's all the same thing identify
ation valuation distribution child
support spousal support custody and
visitation or custody and access that's
it it seems cruel or like jaded to say
to people yeah yeah I don't look at it
like I look at it just like your doctor
looks at you like like meat you know
what I mean like your your your fiance
probably doesn't worry that her
gynecologist is checking out her naked
body you know like she just goes yeah
like this what they see all day like
this just meat you're just meat to them
They Don't Really Care you know and it's
the same divorce lawyers it's like we
don't really get down in the muck of
like who's the good guy who's the bad
guy like it really is okay what's there
what are we doing with the kids how are
we gonna what are the problems what are
the legal issues how do we identify them
how do we solve for them how do we
create leverage cultivate leverage and
how do we use leverage in the
negotiation or litigation how do you
prevent your spouse from cheating on you
just put like air tags and geotagging
and everything and don't let them out of
the house you know the know the old joke
is you know uh um you know what you call
a woman who always knows where her
husband is a
widow um you know I don't I don't think
you can answer the question how do you
prevent that I think you can say how do
you control for it and I think there's
probably a lot of different answers I
mean my
answer my answer to that would be to try
to maintain connection with your partner
you know try to I don't believe people
cheat when they're happy I've SE I'm I'm
an expert on infidelity now like I've
spent a lot of time with the cheated on
and a lot of time with the cheaters over
the course of a two decade career and I
got to tell you yeah you spend enough
time with either of them I wish there
were good guys and bad guys there kind
of aren't like it's just but you've
never seen someone you're like okay this
person just seemingly acted in bad like
yeah with malice they wanted to hurt the
other person there's got to be a
personality sort of trait that might
deviate more towards cheating than
others yeah well you just said two
different things though one of the
things you just said is that they did
this to hurt the other person rarely
seen people who cheat to hurt the other
person usually you're not thinking about
the other person and you should have
been like I don't know a lot of people
that are like I'm going to go out and
cheat on my partner usually what it is
is they go out and they like the
affection of this other person they like
the attention of this other person and
then they cross lines they shouldn't
have crossed and they're not doing it to
hurt their partner they're doing it to
make themselves feel good and they're
not thinking about their partner which
they should be doing doing at that
moment they should be thinking about
like I don't eat chocolate cake cuz I
want to screw my diet no like I want to
eat chocolate cake because chocolate
cake tastes good and I don't think about
my diet and I go you know what I I'll
work out extra tomorrow and then
tomorrow comes and you didn't work out
extra and now you ate your chocolate
cake like so I think it's a matter of
what are the incentives and what are the
motivations now again I don't know how
much intention matters like what really
matters is how you treat the people that
you love you know it doesn't matter what
your intentions were so I'm not saying
intentions are irrelevant like if I
punch you in the face because I don't
like you versus I hit you in the face
because there's a mosquito on your face
like those are two different intentions
important in that situation but cheating
is one of those things that you know did
you cheat because you're lonely did you
cheat because you're stupid and you just
didn't think about it like I've had
people come into my office and say to me
like yeah I got caught cheating and you
go like okay you know they go yeah I'm
an idiot like God I I love my wife so
much and I I don't know I just like saw
the shiny object and I went after it and
it was a mistake and I'm an idiot you
know and that breaks your heart it
breaks your heart because I understand
like I'm human like I've I've seen a
shiny object and chased it I've eaten
things I shouldn't eat done things I
shouldn't have done I feel like there's
got to be more to it if you love the
person think about them and you regret
it afterward I I feel like there's got
to be something underlying that was
always there that would prompt you to go
and do something like that or maybe
there's a personality trait that's a
little more likely to do that I mean
wouldn't it be nice if that was true I'd
feel a whole lot safer you know like I
think we all want that to be true right
like when you're little you get told
like don't smoke cigarettes and you know
like Drive the speed limit you know
you'll be like that right then you hear
about aneurysms where like one day
you're just sitting there and then
you're dead and there's no Rhyme or
Reason to it if you ask a doctor well
how do I prevent aneurysms they go you
can't and you go well how do you know
you're going to have one you don't so
how does it happen God just goes eeny
meeny miny mo and then takes you out
well what can I do as warning signs
nothing you'll have a headache and then
five minutes later you'll be dead you
know okay well that's pretty scary I'd
like a world where there's more control
than that so let's talk about those
other things let's talk about what I can
do to increase my chain I'll do zone two
cardio that's good right yes that is
good that is good that will help prevent
things will it prevent aneurysms not at
all so cheating yeah okay man you're
engaged I get it like you want to
believe like my personality traits and
her personality traits are such that we
will not cheat on each other God man I
wish I could say that to you like I wish
I could say to you that like oh no
here's the four thing I wish I could
give you like a buzzfeed list here's the
10 things that you should watch out for
here's the five things you can do that
you'll you'll adultery proof your
marriage wouldn't that be like that
would just be great clickbait five
things to guarantee your partner won't
cheat you know here's three signs your
partner's definitely cheating like
that's going to get a lot of views it's
it's not true like the truth is
is that the line of Good and Evil runs
through the human heart you know like we
are all just flawed people that you know
again I'm not suggesting that there
aren't people who are remarkably
shortsighted like if you want to ask me
what personality traits I think they're
all kind of the same like people who are
very shortsighted people who don't trade
you know trading what you want now for
what you want most that's the definition
of discipline y so if you're not someone
who can be disciplined in life you're
probably more likely to cheat because
what is cheating cheating in a
relationship adultery in a relationship
is rather than doing the hard thing
which is sitting down with your partner
and saying hey I don't know man like
we're not I'm not feeling satisfied like
I'm not feeling like that that hunger
because what is what is sex but hunger
I'm hungry right I'm hungry I can eat
healthy choices that are going to be
good for me and the next day I'll feel
good or I can go out and eat terrible
food that's going to make me feel bad an
hour but man it tastes good and trust me
adultery tastes good oh my God are you
kidding me it's chocolate cake it's new
it's it's novel it's something different
come on gang like let's all just be
honest with each other but is it what
you want no it's garbage it's junk food
like we all know if you can have a
fulfilling loving deep satisfying
connection that's exciting with someone
who's always there for you and you're
always there for them and you support
each other emotionally too but you also
really have a lot of fun in bed that's
the greatest that's the lottery that's
the greatest thing yeah so that's the
question but that's a harder thing
because the question is not
well what's the personality type look at
the question is how do I cultivate that
and the answer isn't sexy it's like how
do I get rich work hard you know think
think through your choices be careful
invest in a disciplined way don't be
emotional about it like those that's not
sexy advice so the advice we should
really be giving to people is like just
pay attention pay attention like right
now you and your fiance you're at the
best place you're ever going to be like
you're you're you've chosen each other
you know and and you have tremendous
good willll towards each other and you
love each other now is the time to
figure out why do we feel so good about
each other and how do we keep it going
and how are we going to have a
conversation when we start to feel it
slip and not feel attacked and not feel
judged and not make the other person
feel bad for saying it like if your
romantic partner says to you hey I'm I'm
feeling like my eye is
wandering like they're telling you that
for a reason because they don't want it
to they don't want to feel that way I
don't want to cheat on you so so you
should hear that as a as an expression
of love and value but but you don't I
understand that if your if your
girlfriend came home and said to you
like yeah I've been been looking at
other guys lately your first reaction is
going to be what what's wrong well why
what do you do well you know you know
many other girls talk to me and I don't
run out but wait like they just shared
this with you because they're trying to
tell you something and maybe the answer
is yes so maybe we shouldn't get married
or maybe we shouldn't stay in this
marriage but maybe the answer is okay
wait what can I do to to spice things
and make things good and make you feel
that way about me like she was once a
girl you wanted to get with you know and
you were once a guy she wanted to get
with like every beautiful woman you ever
see right now someone somewhere is tired
of that like that's the reality like no
one's a hero to their Butler like no
one's a hero to someone they see every
single day necessarily so shiny new
things are always going to be there so
the question really is How brave are you
how disciplined are you how willing are
you to have scary conversations like
that and that's why I think prenup
people who have prenups are less likely
to get divorced because it's proof that
you can have a hard conversation but a
necessary one right what keeps the
mystery alive in a relationship for them
to stay together for such a long time
desire is such a weird thing right like
no desire is a weird when my my kids
were little I was trying to sort of
explain to them early like because you
know I have a lot of gay and lesbian
friends and it was like trying to
explain to a four-year-old what it means
to be gay you know it was kind of like a
weird you know because he'd be like does
he have a wife and I was like well he
doesn't have a wife he's he's gay what
does that mean you're like uh well you
know and I remember saying well you know
like you know how I like to kiss Mommy
and I like that mommy has pretty blonde
hair well that's what I like you know
but he likes you you know guys who have
nice short hair and that's what he likes
but what matters in life is that you
find someone you like to kiss and they
like to kiss you and you love each other
and that's what matters right so that's
kind of how I tried to teach that to my
kids I'm sure I'll get pillared for that
in the tron space um but the reality is
that that look I I think desire is
something that's very unique to each of
us what we like what we want I think
knowing what you want is really
important and then knowing how to
express that to your partner is really
important and I think it's
better to express it in a positive way
than in a negative way and the example I
give of this is I have to shave five
days a week I have to be clean cut I
have to look like Perry Mason you know
courtroom lawyer especially the like you
know white old judges I have to look
very like what they'd imagine a lawyer
to look like so I can't grow a beard so
I shave five days a week so on the
weekends I don't shave I really like not
having to shave and I remember dating a
girl who she had very s II skin so
anytime I would kiss her if I hadn't
shaved it was the weekend she would be
like oh like you know and I remember
like I would get kind of annoyed because
she'd be like oh your beard is so
scratchy and I would be like all right
you know what then I won't kiss you how
about that like that's like come on like
I work five days a week I got to shave
and drag this razor across my face and
get razor burn like you can't just let
me you know like let but it because it
felt like a criticism it didn't work out
with that girl the next person I dated
she had the same thing sensitive skin I
have a rough beard I didn't want to
shave on the weekend
but she was brilliant because it was
like a Friday or a Thursday and I'd
shaved and she comes up and she goes oh
God like it's so sexy when you're fresh
shaved like that I love like your skin
like it's so like you're like Don Draper
on Mad man I love it dude I would have
shaved three times a day I shaved every
weekend I anytime I was going to see her
I shaved and I'd be like oh yeah I would
kiss her and I'd be like yeah I shaved
this morning she be like yeah I love it
you know okay you did the same thing
like you both just wanted to express the
same thing except one of you did it in a
way that made me in L defensive and the
other one did it in a way that was like
I love this about you and then I'm like
that that's easy I can serve that up
easy I do that all week I can I can
shave no I'll shave twice a day if you
want me to so it's the same thing like
if you share with your partner in the
positive right like I love when you do
this like praising the positive you know
even by the way if they don't do it like
even if they don't do it like I've
always told guys like the best way is a
life hack if the best way to get your
partner to do new things
sexually is to say I had a dream about
you last night I don't even want to tell
you about it she'll be like wait what
why you be like I don't know what it was
but I got to not eat dairy before bed I
I don't even want to say anything no no
what what was it you know you're gonna
think I'm crazy like and then you
describe whatever it was you're having a
fantasy about and at least it'll start a
conversation and if she goes oh my God
that's disgusting you could go yeah no I
know it's so disg can't like like what
was that about I I would never want to
do that in real life it was just a dream
it was a weird dream I got to stop
eating Edibles before bed or she's gonna
go like oh did you did you like that you
be like yeah I don't know like I didn't
think I would but it was kind of hot
really well I would I wouldn't be
against really you know and that's how
but again rather than going well you
never do this or watching a movie and
going like well we never do that like
like which is nothing all you're going
to want to do in response to that is go
well because you didn't ever say you
wanted to go to do that you know so it's
the same thing like just you can you can
incentivize so easily and that's not
just romantic relationships you can do
that in any relationship you know it
really does not have to be about
criticizing your partner it can be about
you know expressing what your needs and
desires are in ways that don't bring out
the defensive side of them how can a guy
be a girl's hero in a relationship I
feel like every guy wants to be seen as
a heroic person yeah to his girl yeah
that's a great question I think first of
all I think being
heroic we we sometimes Define it by
these giant grand gestures you know like
saving the damsel from the train tracks
or saving the puppies from the you know
drowning in the lake but you know being
heroic is really about like being
someone's hero right like putting their
needs maybe above your own sometimes or
or like doing the I mean what is heroic
but doing the hard thing you know like I
I told my sons when they were growing up
I was like I don't know that I have a
lot of wisdom to share with you but if
you were to say to me what is one
sentence that you think is the most
important sentence to tell a human being
I would say the hard thing to do and the
right thing to do are almost always the
same thing in every sphere of Life the
hard thing and the right thing are
almost always the same thing and what is
the hero but the person who does the
hard thing because it's right and it's
good right that's what the hero is like
think about it like every every movie
you've ever watched where like the hero
you know says to the woman I got to go
like I gotta go fight that bad guy or I
gotta go take out the villain who's in
The Saloon or I gotta go on this Mission
and she goes no please don't don't go
stay stay with me stay here stay with us
if he went yeah you're right screw that
let's go back inside he's not the hero
anymore the hero when she says that
kisses her tells her I love you or if
he's Han Solo he just does the I know
which is so cool and then goes and does
what he has to do because that's why
he's the hero because he does the hard
thing because it's the right thing you
know and it's for the benefit not even
just for himself it's for the benefit of
of the group or of her so how do you be
heroic I think the way you're heroic is
you don't Sherk a task like and I think
that's something that's starting to come
into the popular zist is this idea that
like man the world we're all we're
pushing so Comfort down the throat of
everybody you know like everything is
about how can you be more comfortable
you be more comfortable and and I see a
lot of men now choosing discomfort you
know doing cold plunges you know doing
sick workouts you know like intermittent
fasting they're all doing hard stuff you
know and they're they're doing it for
the reason Joe Rogan says he does it Joe
Rogan's like I do workouts in the
morning that are so brutal that the rest
of my day whatever happens it's not
going to be as hard as that workout was
and there's a lot lot of logic to that
there's this stoicism out there that
makes sense so I think the way to be
heroic is what it is always been which
is to put the the the needs and values
and goals of your partner in a place of
high esteem I'm not saying it should
always be above yours but it should be
in a place of high esteem you know and I
think that's that's that's how you are
heroic I think heroic is not just these
giant gestures it's lots of little
things how do you feel like the current
dating culture and Society is affecting
relationships today well I think people
have Choice paralysis I mean in dating I
think Choice paralysis is a huge thing
there's just two there's so many options
there's so many dating apps there's so
many but all of them are very
image-based very performative so I think
that you know I think we're we're living
in a time where everyone has bright
teeth and rotting gums you know we're
really interested in what looks good you
know everybody you know my secretary for
many years drove a really nice Mercedes
and I drove a Jeep Wrangler you know I
know I made more money than her because
I pay her salary but she was very
performative you know and so I think we
live in a very performative Society
right now and I think dating there's a
lot of performative stuff going on in
the world of dating and there's this is
the way people are meeting is largely
online now and so it's a lot of artifice
and performance and you know if you look
at most people's Instagram it's not who
they are it's who they aspire to be or
it's who they want the world to think
they are you know and and I think that
that is um I think it's human I
understand why we do it but I think it's
difficult for dating purposes I think
that dating would in in its best format
there'd be a tremendous amount of
honesty fairly early in the relationship
you know like I understand you want to
see her with makeup on on the first date
but you want to see her shortly after
that without any makeup on you know like
I I get I don't think makeup is lying
you know makeup is accentuating the
positive and dentu the negative like
your Instagram is the same thing like
you're accentuating the positive dentu
the negative it's not lying but
eventually you want people's personality
take the makeup off you know I want to
see what you really look like I want to
see what you really act like I want to
see what you're really afraid of what
you're really good at like I want to see
what you need to work on so I think the
barriers to to to successful
relationships are now what they always
were which is you don't know yourself
that well and you're not good at being
honest with another person about it and
relationships become a form of habit
like I know people that are in unhappy
relationships and they're getting
married and you go why are you getting
married if you're unhappy with each
other and they go we've been together
for like seven years I'm not going to
just walk away from it now like really
really because I would it's not going to
get better once you get married I think
dating right now it's a it's a difficult
time there's too many options there's a
lot of options I want don't say too many
there's a lot of options out there and
it's a lot of performative stuff and
again I I think there's a lot more
intelligent people than me who've talked
a lot about how the dating game the
online dating game is really rigged in
favor of a very small percentage of men
it's really bad for a large group of men
and it's really bad for a large group of
women for what they really want which is
a long-term partner not just someone who
will sleep with them why does it seem so
hard to appreciate the relationship
you're in I feel like it's nearly
impossible to not be influenced by
Hollywood's portrayal of a successful
relationship or like you said social
media's portrayal of a successful
relationship how do you know that what
you're in is true like what is a
guarantee and also like is it even wrong
that I'm asking myself this question or
asking you this question I don't think
there's anything wrong about that
question at all I actually think it's a
great way to look at things look it's
porn romcoms are porn it's porn for
women that's all it is like like the
truth is is that there is is there is a
tremendous what is that but an idealized
stylized fake version of sex right like
when you when you look at sex on a
screen okay I always joke about shower
sex like every movie has a sex scene in
the shower it looks awesome sex in the
shower looks so good you've had sex in
the shower it's terrible it's terrible
sex in the shower is the worst it looks
good it's terrible in practice you're
standing it's kind of weird you're
there's water washing everything off
it's not great okay but it looks really
good so it's in Hollywood so now
everybody looks at it and goes like Oh
we should that's so hot but it's not in
practice it's not right so at the end of
the day I'm G to get pillared by the way
in the comments now people being like I
have wonderful s sex so the truth is
like I genuinely believe
romcoms are just a way of like it's an
idealized version of things it's not
necessarily honest and again what starts
to happen is like the tail wags the dog
because people start to compare their
relationship to that idealized stylized
thing and then they start to go well I
don't have a good one because it's not
like that or they start to try to
pretend to have that you know I know
plenty of men who they they think the
way they should act during sex is what
they've seen on the screen on their
computer and that's not a great
education to the reality of of men and
women having sex so I don't know that
like I I think the problem is that that
of course the ideal the fiction it's the
best version of something or at least it
becomes the best version because it's
what was shoved down our throat all the
time of what it should be but those are
tropes like they're tropes like the idea
of like the girl boss is what's hot now
so everybody's being told in Hollywood
you're girl boss every movie's a girl
boss she's a girl boss she's a girl
she's great at everything she's better
than all the men at everything the only
thing holding her back is men okay that
not only is that a tired tired Trope now
but it doesn't reflect what every woman
wants like if you don't aspire to be a
girl boss B like I don't know that
everybody wants that there are people
that are now standing up and going you
know I don't I don't know that I want to
be a CEO like I kind of think that it
would be nice to have a family and like
tend to them you know I don't know that
like the best place the most satisfying
place to be is in a cubicle from 9 to5
like I actually think like you know
having someone who cares about me and
provides and protects me that's nice you
know and so but that's a dirty thing to
say anymore why because there's been
this stylized version of what your
life's supposed to look like why is it
why is it leaning towards that though do
you think that gender rules exist for a
reason and why do you I do think they
exist for a reason but I think we are a
culture that has always treated dandruff
with decapitation like we always go the
other way way too hard like only an
idiot would say that the 1950s made
sense they didn't men had no choice but
to just put you get to work and shut up
and you're not there to take care of
your kids that's what your wife is for
and you're not allowed to be gay or
you're not allowed to be anything you
could be when I even Me growing up I'm
51 when I was growing up you could be
Clintwood or Richard Simmons those were
your two choices guys you didn't get to
be anything in between there's nothing
in between if you were the slightest bit
nice or you cared about art or you
weren't that interested in football you
were a and that's hor it's a
horrible thing my mother is was
brilliant she was an incredible
mathematician she was told you get to be
a nurse or a teacher and she was like
wait I'm the best math student student
in the class maybe I'll want to go to
med school and they were like you can be
a nurse you can be a teacher those are
your choices until you find a husband
and then you can be a wife you be a mom
those are your choices so I think we
needed to fix that and we did but we did
what we always do we wildly
overcorrected and it turned into you
want to stay home and take care of kids
G like what is this 1950 you could be a
CEO and and and and then suddenly women
were like you know afraid to go like but
I kind of don't want to be a CEO I kind
of wanted to be a teacher you know you
don't have to be a teacher I know I I
want to be a teacher but you don't have
to be you could be a CEO okay like I get
and by the way the capitalist Machinery
loves it loves it let's get everybody in
the workforce let's get every let's make
everybody a cog in the machine you know
so yeah of course so capitalism bolsters
it endlessly but at the end of the day
are people happier no they're miserable
people are miserable now they are less
happy they're as unhappy probably as
they were in 1950 we just the data
better so is the solution now to to go
the other way again to go like all men
have to this and all women have to this
I don't think so I think that was
ridiculous and horrible you know but you
don't H it doesn't have to be so extreme
everything in our culture is so extreme
you can believe that gay and lesbian
people have a right to love each other
marry each other have rights you know be
be treated with respect and not support
drag queen Story Hour for for children
those are two totally different things
you can say a woman has the right and
should be for when a little girl she
should be told you can be a surgeon you
could be the president or you could be a
mom or you could be a teacher or you
could be a person who does potery all
day you could be all those things that's
what feminism is and and feminism
benefits men when it's done properly not
the ridiculous version of it that's out
there now but when it's done properly I
was raised in a feminist household I was
told
that I didn't have to be strong or tough
but being strong and tough are still
admirable traits like so it was
cultivated in me to yeah be my this is
why I was so blessed to have the parents
I had my father was a very traditional
right-wing kind of a guy and he was like
no a man's a provider he's a protector
he knows how to fight he knows you know
he's not afraid like he puts the people
he he's fighting not because he hates
the person in front of him because he
loves the people behind him who he's
protecting you know and that was what I
was taught but my mother also taught me
but but but it's okay you can be sad you
can be afraid like by the way if you're
not scared it's not brave it's only
Brave if you're scared and you do it
anyway that's what being brave is so I I
feel like we've now created a culture
where just no at whatever you're doing
you're doing it wrong if you're a man
who's strong and protective you're
getting pillared for all that's such a
traditional gender role you're so out of
day and if you're the other you're a soy
boy and you're not strong and why why
are we doing this to ourselves guys like
we all have in US fear and strength and
women have strength and fear a woman can
protect me I can protect her we can
protect each other in different ways you
know you can protect me emotionally I
can protect you physically or maybe you
can protect me physically and I'll
protect you emotionally like we can do
what suits our individual Constitution
and so yeah I think we're all lost right
now but we don't and so to then say
we're lost individually so why are our
marriages lost because the ingredient if
the ingredients suck the dinner's going
to suck guys
like the ingredients are lost right now
so the couple double lost right now yeah
what do you think the solution is to
that I think the solution is is the
thing which is yeah it's really hard to
be in a couple right now because we each
don't know ourselves and we don't know
what to do but when it's done right a
couple can fix that like you can see
each other's blind spots you can call
each other out with love you can say
like it's okay to be vulnerable or you
can say to to someone who's having
trouble being strong like you're strong
I know you're strong I'm cheering for
you you know like this is beautiful like
we we we break in relationship and we
can heal in relationship like you can't
you can't fix alone what was broken in
relationship like if you if someone
betrayed your trust in a relationship
they cheated on you you're not going to
fix that by sitting in a room by
yourself ruminating over it you're going
to fix it by going out there again and
trying again and learning that you can
trust someone that not everyone's going
to betray you you know like that's how
you learn so I think the solution is
relationships but but Fearless
relationships honest relationships
relationships where we pay attention
where we value it and we're we're we're
again brutally honest with each other
listen I'm a romantic at heart but I
don't believe in fairy tales so don't I
don't believe in a culture that shoves
fairy tales down people's throats I
think we should be that real flawed
Human Relationships is really beautiful
to me and it's really romantic to me so
you talk about being brutally honest in
relationships we had a clip that went
viral of me asking our guest Tom Bilu
actually what do you tell your wife if
you think she doesn't look great in the
dress and we've asked this question a
few times in the podcast but I want to
know what your answer is to this
question what if she does not look good
in that dress what do you say and how
can you approach it in a more like
delicate way like you also said on on
Lex Freedman I think um when she asks
like oh how was that after you guys were
in bed together or whatever and and
maybe it wasn't the best you've ever had
but she's asking you was it the best
you've ever had like how do you approach
that conversation yeah so I think those
are two different examples but the the
the outfit one I think is a lot easier
and and that is I remember my ex-wife I
don't think she'd be mad at me for
sharing this with the world but she was
always very concerned about like does my
butt look big in this this is when Big
Butts were not a good thing that changed
generation okay but a '9 this is the
'90s yeah this and she was very upset
about the fact that like you know and by
the way lovely beautiful woman beautiful
woman was then still is um but she was
always women are so much more critical
of themselves than we are of them you
know like I wish they could see us they
could see themselves through our eyes
you know but she was very like do I my
and I would never you know like I knew
what she was saying she was insecure
like she wanted there to be some Praise
of her but there were some things she'd
wear that were not as flattering So my
answer to that was always I would point
out something she looked even better in
so she'd say how do I look in this dress
and I go I like it you know and and why
are you asking and she'd say well
because I feel like maybe it's it and I
go oh okay yeah I mean you know that
black dress that you wore to that other
thing you look and that you looked great
that really just and then she'd put that
on and I go oh yeah that's the one like
that's the that just does I don't know
it's just something about your coloring
or your figure that just does it you
know and okay you know and that what is
that it's the same Jedi mind trick that
with my shaving it's positive
reinforcement it's positive
reinforcement but it's honest but it's
just not making a person self-conscious
about something they're already
self-conscious about like so the same
thing with sex like you know I like to
again focus on how when someone says how
was that I mean first of all I don't
know how often people say like how was
that I if you have to ask it probably
wasn't that good but I I think that
sharing with your partner what they did
well like to me I mean look we all do
this in in romantic relationships you
first start dating someone you just
throw everything at it you're like let
me try every trick I've ever tried in
bed with anyone but what you start to
figure out is oh this one doesn't like
the same things as the other one did or
this one you know like and and she's
maybe doing the same thing with you like
the higher the body count maybe the like
more complicated the equation but you
try stuff until you figure out what each
of you likes and you usually figure it
out by what you get positive feedback on
like what makes this person moan or what
makes this person like when they say oh
my God that was so when you did this and
you go okay great noted you know so I
get it like I think that's the way to do
it is to share with each other what the
other one's doing right because if you
don't me if I do the same three things
and you only praise two of them I'm
going to know eventually okay you didn't
praise that third one and then if
somebody says to you like you know hey
you never mentioned that you like that
third one you don't have to say I don't
like the third one you can say like yeah
I mean those other two are so good that
like I don't know you can put that one
by the side it doesn't matter I don't
need it you know and so there's ways to
to again to be a cheerleader for your
partner and I in my book I call this um
uh that like you know psych
psychological manipulation but in a
positive way yeah like it's a positive
mind control you know it's it's you're
trying to really drive home what they're
doing right which will then sort of show
the corollary of what what is not right
what do you think is something important
that everyone should be asking their
partner that they don't I think there's
a lot of good answers to that question
question I mean one of them would be
what am I doing right like what do you
like best about me you I know that's
going to sound like a selfish question
but it actually is that sometimes I
don't think we know what people like
about us like I we're not always a good
gauge of what our partner finds most
attractive about us um I I think that
there's more important things to do like
I think sharing with your partner what
you like about them and what you find
challenging in the relationship is more
important than asking that question of
your partner
but I I think asking your partner like
what are their you know what are their
what are they afraid of right now what
are they grateful for right now you know
there's a lot of
really easy but deep conversations to be
had with a partner you know and and you
can understand a lot about some like
what are you excited for in the next
year you know what are you afraid of
right now like these are deep questions
you know and and and I don't know how
much incentive there is in our culture
to ask those questions of your partner
again it might be in the context of like
let's just go for a walk or let's just
devote an hour a week to like you don't
even need a coup couples counselor to do
this with like let's just you know ask
each other those questions like what are
you grateful for this week like what did
I do right this week as your partner and
I'll I'll tell you what you did right
you know in in this like we're human
beings like you and I right now can have
this conversation like I could say to
you you know hey what have I done right
as a guest for the last couple of hours
and and and I could tell you what I
think you've done really well in this
conversation and then we're both going
to get better not only at this
conversation but at the next
conversation that you have or the next
time I'm a guest but but we don't do
that because we're just supposed to
naturally be excellent at everything and
then after we'll find out if we got it
right or we got it wrong and I don't why
why like why are we you know we're
building a bridge while we drive over it
like why don't we have some
conversations about how am I doing how
are you doing here's what you did so
great last week or here's what last week
we kind of missed the pl on you know
like that's important it seems like the
solution to a lot of these issues
because there's so many different
Bridges to cross in relationships the
main thing to consider would be just
having those deeper conversations
whatever they are because I feel like a
lot of people in relationships and I've
experienced this in my relationships as
well you kind of just go through the
motions and time passes and you know
you're enjoying your time but there
could be some dissonance slowly
increasing between you two yeah and I
think maybe just continuing to have
these deeper
conversations and being maybe
intentional and aware about that would
probably be a generally good rule of
thumb that can fix up a lot of the
wounds that people have in their
relationship I think it's not only a
good idea it's the good idea like that I
think I think people their relationships
fall apart the way that people go
bankrupt very slowly and then all at
once I think you have to do routine
maintenance all the time on a
relationship and it's a whole lot easier
it's a whole lot easier to keep your
weight where you want it to be than it
is to get really overweight and then try
to lose the weight it's so much easier
to stay connected to someone who loves
you and you love them and you're happy
with each other then it is to find
distance disconnect and then try to find
your way back it's so much harder so
just staying connected and all that is
is just a matter of disciplined routine
habits that honor what's best in this
person and what's Best in you and I I
don't think it's I don't think it's that
hard it just requires discipline do you
think if you are once in love with
somebody like true love with somebody
that that relationship can stay true all
the way until the end as long as you are
intentional about it or do you think
that there are some random extraneous
things that can happen I well I think
you're one person in the relationship so
the other person also has an equal share
of having to maintain if the true love
let's say was reflected yeah so I think
if you're two people that have a true
depth of connection and love for each
other and you both approach this
relationship with the same seriousness
are there still do bombs still fall out
of the sky like is there still aneurysms
yeah there are like i' I've represented
the the most
heartbreaking cases I have are when
someone's lost a child the divorce rate
for people who have a child who dies is
through the roof and and it's
heartbreaking it's heart I've done about
five divorces where people lost a child
like one of them the kid fell in the
pool and they they found this
three-year-old they found you know and
this other one parent was like why
weren't you watching them but they they
know that it was like they turned their
head for a second and the kids snuck out
like it was nobody's fault but they
forever then were reminding each other
of of this thing that was taken from
them and they break up the problem with
that
is that's like someone saying to you um
if I said I want to quit smoking and
someone says well I know someone who
lived to 100 and Still Smoked Cigarettes
like right but they're in the manor
like that's not usually what it is like
most marriages don't end because they
lost a child like so are there still
things yep there's still things like you
can take the best care of yourself and
you can walk out and get hit by a bus so
does that mean that you should just not
invest in your 401k and and smoke
cigarettes like smoke I don't think so
like life is short and and and horrible
things happen all the time and you know
you could love someone so well and so
deeply and they could still break your
heart you know so does that mean mean
don't do it like I don't think so I
think be brave like be brave like get
out there and try you know and so but
but is there a guarantee no there's no
guarantee but do I think if someone has
that strong starting point of a deep
connection and real affection and an
honest love for each other that's deep
and visceral and is that a great place
to start from and is it easier to just
try to keep that from day one than to
like I kind of like this person and
maybe they're a fixer uper and I could
tournament that's not a great place to
start from so I think good Beginnings
can lead to you know good endings if
you're Vigilant um but yeah there's
still always bombs get full out of the
sky have you ever been settling a
divorce and you thought that they were
actually still really good for each
other yeah yeah several times and what
happens in situations like that have you
ever brought it up or is it just not
your place whatsoever I bring it up yeah
I bring it up I I I don't I mean I work
from the assumption that people have
autonomy and agency so I don't like to
be paternal and say to people like why
are you guys splitting up but if in a
consultation I get any sense that
there's hope for a marriage to to to
remain I encourage people I have a whole
network of marriage therapists
individual therapists who I'll refer
people to if I think that they could
divorce amicably I'll send them to a
mediator instead of me I'll tell them
listen I'm a chainsaw you want to
scalpel it's fine just go mediate you're
better off like I'm a very specific set
of tools you know like I'm a weapon you
know you don't want to point me at
somebody unless you want to do harm so I
would say that that more than once I
have said to someone hey look it sounds
like you guys are kind of in a good
place and it sounds like maybe you're
not sure you want to do this and don't
just because you hired lawyers see this
thing through especially if you got kids
like if there's a way to make a marriage
work that you'll both be happy like do
that do that without question you know
I'd love to be out of business have you
ever felt morally conf inflicted when
you're representing a case like you said
you're us as a weapon against somebody
else but maybe in this case you feel
like you're asking for a lot something
that you maybe morally have deemed not
fair but you're just doing your job
assigned by a Marketplace to basically
represent your client yeah yeah that
happens all the time if if any lawyer
who says to you that they don't
represent positions or people that that
make them morally uncomfortable is
either lying or has a very inert
practice like yeah I represent horrible
people sometimes so how do you toy with
that in your bra I believe in our system
I believe in democracy I believe in I
believe in the way our justice system
works that people are entitled to
vigorous advocacy under the bounds of
advocacy like I don't I don't listen I I
there's a chapter in my book about a
case I should not have won I represented
a horrible person who beat a woman
unmercifully and we won because I knew
the Rules of Evidence better than the
other lawyer and he had more money so he
could afford me and she got a court
assigned lawyer who had hardly any idea
what they were doing and I ate their
lunch for them and as we walked out he
patted me on the shoulder and he said
one good lawyer is better than 20
stickup men and I remember I felt dirty
I felt dirty like when I recorded my
audio book and I read that chapter into
the microphone in the sound booth I had
to stop because I got choked up because
I felt really weird about it but the
thing is I believe in our system I
believe in democracy I believe in the
rule of law I believe in advocacy and I
didn't cheat in that case I won Under
the rule set that everyone agreed on and
it's not my fault that that lawyer
doesn't know how to try a case and it's
not my fault that so I I believe in our
system I don't think I should be the one
our system doesn't think the lawyer
should be the one who makes a moral
decision as to who like people have a
right to
representation and I do the best I can
for them are there times where I feel
icky about that absolutely but more
often than not
I don't more often than not I'm I'm
advocating for someone I believe in but
now you could say that she did not get
the same level of service that you were
able to deliver because she didn't have
the resources capitalism baby you get as
much justice as you can afford like
there's a reason why OJ walked it ain't
because he wasn't guilty like there's it
the reality is that you get you know our
system listen I'm not saying it's always
that if you have more money you win but
you have a significant tactical
Advantage if you have good lawyers like
if you afford a good lawyer like we're
better we're better at this job so we'll
do a better job you know it's not it's
not quite so simple like a a really good
Chef you know can take good ingredients
and make an amazing meal they can take
junky ingredients and still make a
really good meal they can't take junk
ingredients and make it into something
fantastic no no Chef in the world can
but a bad Chef you can take bad
ingredients make bad choic you take good
ingredients you'll make bad meal like
that like a good lawyer is worth a lot
so you're faith in the system is not
bulletproof right because you gave the
example of like when you represented
this person you didn't think that you
should have won the case well no I
should have won the case I just felt
badly about right okay do you think that
there's ever a point in the future where
you can forsake your faith in the system
to adjudicate on your own behalf and
think like okay this is what should
happen let's just say you had a billion
dollars it's your last case ever now
obviously this is a very tricky no but
you know got to ask the I love this
question I've never been asked it and I
love it and what I'll say to you is I'll
tell you how the sausage is made I'll
tell you a secret this is what lawyers
fantasize about when we fantasize that's
what we fantasize about we fantasize
about I fantasize about two things more
often than I'd care to admit one is
telling a judge what I actually think
like I have fantasies about Jud in the
middle of Court being like you know what
you're an idiot you're an idiot I'm a
better lawyer than you you don't know
the law you're lazy you know what you
call a lawyer with a 70 IQ your honor
okay like I want to say someday in court
I plan to get dragged off in handcuffs
because I said that to guarant it's
gonna happen stay tuned so that's one
thing I fantasize about the other thing
I I really F and by the way there are
some phenomenal judges who know the law
and are way better lawyers than me and
they do it for the right reasons but
there's also some terrible ones and
unlike bad lawyers bad judges can hurt a
lot of people really badly so that's why
we have to have good
judges the other thing we fantasize
about is betraying attorney client
privilege like calling the other side
anonymously and saying look in the bank
accounts at blah blah blah blah blah
he's hiding money and then just hanging
up the phone like I have fantasies about
like taking a cell phone or a burner
phone and like just narking on something
that I know that is like you know or
here's where those photographs are or
send a subpoena for the audio recordings
on his thing because you're gonna find X
Y and Z that's what we fantasize about
I'd never do it but that's what we
fantasize about but if your your client
is asked about potentially missing funds
or something like that wouldn't it be
perjury if they if I know yes we can't
suborn perjury it's why criminal defense
lawyers will tell you the question they
never asked their clients is did you do
it because once the client tells you
that if the client says yes I did it you
can't suborn perjury so clients don't
come in and say to you I'm hiding money
or I'm hacking her email and I'm reading
her emails with her lawyer they just
like know stuff and and you are afraid
to say how do you know this because
they'll go I have her email hacked like
every once in a while I have an idiot
who says like yeah I hacked her email in
her cell phone and I Gog great I'm off
your case now because you're asking me
to suborn per you're committing a crime
that's wiretapping it's a felony you're
intercepting electronic communications
to which you're not an intended
recipient that's a crime and you're now
telling me that you're giving me
information that you only know because
you're cpit usly intercepting
Communications between her and her
lawyer so I can't be your lawyer anymore
those are the rules so that's great when
that happens because i' like to know
like I liked when the KKK wore white
robes instead of three piece suits
because I like to know what someone's
doing I like to know if you're a racist
I like to know who you are I like to
know if you're a criminal but the
reality is is that most of the time
that's not how it works most of the time
people won't say yeah I beat her I beat
her she's totally telling the truth they
go that never happen she was attacking
me and then I pushed her and she hit
herself and fell and you go I don't
believe that but I don't know that it's
false and the system I'm supposed to
credit what my client says until there
is an admission to the contrary you know
there was a great uh YouTube video that
I got recommended last night on the way
here and it was a two-minute video from
a lawyer posted 10 years ago said how do
you represent clients that you know are
guilty and he gave a great example he
said when I first started my career I
represented a client he was guilty he
came up with this elaborate story
involving all these other people but I
knew he was so guilty the proof was
there this guy was guilty and I tried my
best to represent him but he was guilty
and he went to he was found guilty yeah
went to jail he said years later another
case came up with an identical story and
as it turned out that guy was innocent
yeah and he went to jail and he said
after that I learned that I can't let my
own judgments get in the way 100% And
even if something sounds so ridiculous
and I believe in my heart I'm 100% he's
guilty there's a chance he's not
got the same representation here's the
thing about our system the truth fears
no trial the truth has a way of coming
out sometimes despite my best efforts
like I represent some awful people
sometimes and I do my absolute best and
I am great at my job and we lose because
there's only so much like the truth has
a way of coming out like if you're a
liar you got to have a great memory you
got to remember what you told everybody
you got to remember what records are out
there you know like we come after you if
I come after you it's coming out so
there's times where like listen people
want to roll the dice they want to lie
they want to pretend it's okay cool
truth has a way of coming out and I'll
do my best I'll do my best to put
lipstick on a pig but it's still a pig
like I'm gonna do my best but that's the
way our system works it's designed to do
that the system works it's not perfect
but it works a lot of the time the truth
has a way of coming out I've represented
a lot of people who've been accused of
sexual abuse of children cuz those cases
come out Family Court sometimes they're
done as neglect cases so they fall more
into the realm of family law than
criminal law and so I've represented a
lot of people who are facing allegations
of child sexual abuse and there are some
that I go I think this person did it and
then as the evidence comes out I realize
no they didn't and then there are people
that I genuinely go there's no way
there's no way this guy did this and
then as the evidence comes out I go oh
my God he did it you know same thing
with domestic violence I've met
perpetrators of domestic violence who I
would have let them date my sister like
they're they're lovely they're Charming
narcissists you know and and and I've
met perpetrators of domestic violence
that you know I never would have known
that they were abusive but they were you
know I've I I have a case right now
where I'm representing a woman who's you
know accused her husband of very serious
domestic violence and he came into court
and I was like she is lying this guy is
so Charming so nice he's so even keeled
everybody who ever met them was like
he's the nicest guy you ever met and
thank God they have a ring doorbell
because the ring doorbell caught him on
camera beating the out of their
six-month-old Labrador puppy no yep and
kicking this dog and throw grabbing the
leash and yank and smacking it against
the wall and I had to listen to this and
I had to watch this but I have tell you
something and I hated it it was like one
of those moments where I go why am I
doing this for a living but I brought
that into court and I showed that to the
judge how feel it felt good cuz I
brought it in and I showed it to the
judge and the judge went okay she's
telling the truth like she's telling the
truth because this guy came into court
all buttoned up and so lovely and then
you have a video and audio of him
beating the snot out of a six-month old
puppy and you go okay that's what this
guy's really like so that's a beautiful
thing like when you get to feel that
happen when you get to go I was part of
making Justice move forward no one
believed this woman I didn't believe
this woman cuz he seemed real nice you
know Jeffrey dmer seemed nice too to a
lot of people until ate them you know so
like the private lives of people and the
public face of people is very very
different which is why I like the rule
of law and due process because the truth
has a way of coming out how often does
someone's image affect the outcome if
they're buttoned up clean cut versus
someone with like face tattoos and yeah
pretty often pretty often but but again
that's what trials are for tri trials
are full contact
storytelling like in a good Storyteller
you're gonna if I know a client has face
tattoos I got to work harder I I got to
work harder like I had a client who we
were fighting over custody of his
5-year-old
son and he had a baby with a woman who
he had very they had only been dating
for like three months and then she got
pregnant and she had a whole series of
text messages from him where he was
trying to get her to have an abortion
and he was saying to her like I'm not
going to be involved in this kid's life
and you're gonna be a single mom and I
think this is foolish you're ruining
your life having this
kid and this guy loved his son like you
wouldn't believe he loved his son so
much and I said to him I was like we got
to get out in front of this we to get
out in front of this in this trial
because you're going to look like a
terrible person like I read those texts
and I don't like that guy so I put him
on the stand in his trial and before the
other side got a chance to eat him I put
him on and I put those text messages
into evidence and I had him read them
into the record and I said how do you
feel when you read those text messages
and he cried legitimately cried and said
I feel horrified I'm ashamed
he's like I I'm so glad she didn't
listen to me he was like I I feel
disgusted I'll never forgive myself for
that but but I was scared at the time
and I didn't know and I hadn't met my
son yet and thank God she didn't listen
to me and I got because I love my kid
the minut was born I knew like oh my God
I'm so glad so to me like you know again
that's what's so beautiful about this
job is you get to like let the truth
come out you know and and that's that's
an amazing thing to be part of a little
bit of a change of pace but you spoke
before about some really unique alimony
payments some really unique uh prenups
you said that there was one that you
signed where every 10 pounds the woman
in the relationship gains yes she's
going to receive $10,000 less per month
on our alimony payments yes and that
stood up in
court I you know I had that's hilarious
I'm sorry that's funny I'm sorry it's
funny yeah it's very funny of course
it's F it's incredibly funny and what
are some of the other really creative
pre up agreements you've seen can can
you write in literally anything you want
to yeah as long as it's not um as long
as it doesn't require someone to break
the law so you can't put in like if you
kill my brother-in-law I get I'll give
you X Y and Z like it has to be
something that's legal for a person to
do but yeah you can write in all kinds
of crazy creative things like you can
write Fidelity Clauses like if you cheat
you have liquidated damages of this much
but what's interesting what's actually
more interesting about that that no
one's ever asked me about but but a lot
of people found that prenup thing with
the 10 pound you lose 10,000 um what's
funny about that is that here's what
what law school does to your brain I
heard that story and my first thought
was not who's gonna marry this guy like
are you kidding me like that what kind
of person are you nor did I go like yeah
that's a good point man you don't want
her to you know it's the most fattening
food in the world is wedding cake like
you don't you know control that I didn't
look at either of those way I looked at
it and I went all right well wait a
minute how do we establish the Baseline
so when they sign it will there be a
wein because you'd have to establish
Baseline and if there is a baseline if
I'm representing her I'm going to want
to be like wrestling like you don't cut
weight like you're going to want to
bloat up as much as you can and put as
much in your pockets as you can so your
Baseline weight's as high as possible so
that the the gauge the Delta how do you
certify that way and then by the way
when she well and how do you certify
that is written into the doc this is
what so now you're thinking like a
lawyer so I heard that like we cure that
provision and I go okay how are we going
to and then when when we have the we in
at the time of divorce have to calibrate
can she cut weight like is she in a
sauna with the suit on like a boxer or a
wrestler like what are we doing here you
know like to me it became a legal issue
like okay so how would I prove it and
what is the Baseline and how do so I had
to start thinking like in that provision
about okay so we have to put in this
contract the way in the way out who will
will it be neutral like what time of the
month would it be there's women who say
like hey right before my period I I get
blowed up and there's women who say oh
my God like two days after my period I'm
like super lean how do we do it so I was
thinking about it from so a lot of what
lawyers get caught up in is like the
details of what do we prove and when you
say oh cheating Clause like everybody
like a lay person goes like yeah you
should have to pay a penalty when you
cheat okay what how do we Define
cheating how do we Define proving
cheating you know like if you saw me
going into a restaurant with a woman is
it proof I'm cheating or you see me
going into a hotel but if they have a
restaurant in the hotel maybe I'm just
going eat at the restaurant you know so
like what is cheating for the purposes
of fidelity clause for the purposes of a
penalty and again you know you may say
that it has a plain meaning but does it
like if I say to you a reasonable amount
of time what does that mean we might
have three totally different definitions
of a reasonable amount of time so
lawyers are very caught up in how do we
Define things in specific enough ways
that they're enforceable so what are
some of the other really creative
Arrangements you SE well I'm curious in
that case about the the pounds did she
have an objetive to that or was she
totally on board she was on board with
it when they signed it and she resented
it when they she tried to use it as a
basis to set aside the prenup what if
she had lost 10 pounds would it have
increas it did not I asked that question
before they signed it and it it it was
not she didn't get like a bonus she was
a model she had been a model like it was
it was fairly clear that what she
brought to the relationship was that she
was very attractive and what he brought
to the relationship is that he was very
rich did she end up gaining weight um no
she she gained a bit she lost I think
she lost 20 grand a month but she was
getting like yeah she gained like 20
pounds over the course of the marriage
how much was her final alimon amount uh
30 or 40 Grand and how long was the
marriage seven years it was short and
there was no kids okay because we had
actually put in a clause that said if
there were children that that changed oh
interesting okay because we realized
that there was a function of you know so
what are the other creative Arrangements
you've seen I mean I've had a lot of
what's actually interesting to me is is
the um and it maybe not be as
interesting to others but uh the like
instead of alimony like I had a you know
like a a hedge fun guy marry like a yoga
teacher and she made like nothing and he
made you know he's in his 30s and made
like three four million a year so he's
doing really well and we were talking
about alimony we're going back and forth
about how much would the alimony be it
should be this percentage of amount
versus how long they're married if
they're married five years or more it'll
be this percentage and if it's this
it'll be this percentage and but then
there was a question of because a lot of
guys in finance like they get paid their
bonuses are often much bigger than their
salary so it was like well do we do it
on last year's salary because last year
might have been a great year it might
have been a bad year so it might not be
indicative so we do like a three-year
average and my client who's a very
pragmatic guy in finance just went yeah
just give her a million bucks and I was
like wait what do you mean and he was
like yeah just if we split up she gets a
million bucks and I was like wait but
like what if you're married like three
months yeah I give her a million bucks
what have you're married 10 years
million bucks you know I was like well
are you sure like you're married three
month months you give her a million
bucks he's like yeah you know I'll make
more money it's fine so those are the
things that I'm sort of shocked by
whereas I have some people in finance
who make you know hundreds of millions
of dollars and they're very like down to
the penny they want to argue over so
what's more fascinating to me is like
how different people's approach to
marriages to finances it's just such a
diversity of people but prenups I mean
I've seen a lot of stuff in prenups
About Pets that's a big thing lately
people put a lot of stuff in About Pets
because people love their pets often as
much as they would their kids and a lot
of times when people are cohabitating
before they get married um I've had
people put in Clauses about family
members that like we won't if we won't
allow this family member in our home you
know or we won't communicate with this
person or that person so it doesn't even
have anything to do with money no but it
has Financial repercussions got it okay
so if you were to talk to this person or
have this person in our household then
you don't get well see lawyer we're very
caught up in the or
what like everything's or what yeah you
know like lawyers are the worst at that
like when you say like you're not
allowed to sit there or what or what
like you know it's very I used to always
get criticized for this because I I park
illegally all the time in New York City
yeah because I'm always like you know
you can't park there for what you get a
$50 ticket no problem that's cool
because this garage over here is $75 for
the amount of time on a park this is a
ticket for 50 bucks no problem I'll give
you 50 bucks to park here and there's a
chance I might not get a ticket so even
better you know so or what it's always
or what you know well you better do this
or what you know I'll give you 20 years
in prison okay good disincentive I will
not do that thing you know but so that's
how prenups are like it's always well I
I want to put in the prenup this okay or
what and how would you enforce it and is
it enforcable you know so like all
that's a lot of our legal system a lot
of our world is based on people's
misunderstanding of their rights so like
you know when you pull your car into a
garage in the city and and there's that
sign that says we are not responsible
for damage to your car you are they are
they are but a lot of people will go
look at they think oh darn it I didn't
say the sign they're not responsible oh
well and they'll drive off like they
believe it so it becomes true but it's
not true like it's not true like they're
not allowed to damage your car it
doesn't matter if they have a sign like
if I have a sign that says if you come
in my house I get to rape you like that
does it's not true it's not true it's
not how it works so it's really really
important that people understand their
rights and their obligations in life I'm
curious what type of relationships you
find to be the most successful we had
Alex rosi on the podcast and he said
that there are different dynamics of
relationships one is a footballer and a
cheerleader where you have someone going
out and you have the cheerleader just
behind you have another where both
people are in the trenches and you have
another where one is very masculine one
is very feminine yeah do you find a
commonality between who's the most
successful the best relationships are
the ones that have some poity you know I
think when when when like marries like
too much that lack of polarity becomes
challenging it becomes almost a
competitive relationship there are
exceptions to this but what I have seen
as a divorce lawyer polarity usually
feeds a relationship but too much
polarity is a problem like if you're a
neat freak and this person is you know
an absolute mess that's not going to
work out well but if I'm like a super
overscheduled tightly wound person and
you're a little more freewheeling and
like see it is then I might organize you
up a bit and you might get me to get out
of my comfort zone a little and that
really works so I really think that that
finding the right amount of polarity is
really really important so you know
hyper masculine hyper feminine or both
very masculine both very feminine I
don't know that either of those are the
best permutation like sometimes in my
experience hyper masculine hyper
feminine like hyper polarity is better
than hyper similarity but that's just
from where I'm sitting as a divorce
lawyer and from my experience in life
and relationships yeah got one last
question before we wrap up yeah you said
on Lex fredman I don't know that I'll
ever love anyone or anything more than I
love the work uh and that was after
nearly an hour of talking about how a
person spouse is the most important
thing uh and the most coveted thing in
their life you said I think there is
something like the womb like cocoon-like
Joy of love when you're just tucked in
and pressed against each other it's just
the two of you that's lovely we're just
dying for connection that connection is
so big it's everything so how can you
have these two things like you have your
spouse and then you have work you said
you don't think that you can ever love a
spouse as much as you love work and I'm
questioning just as a yeah is you in
particular you're not married yeah right
or you were divorced um you you
currently have a girlfriend I don't know
how long you've been with this with this
girlfriend how do you juggle this
extreme love of work because I think
this is a lot of people's problem yeah
at the same point of like having like
relationship arguably everything in life
yeah so I had a benefit that some people
don't have and that is that when I
started my relationship I was
established in my career so I was very
as advertised like I was very open about
the fact that the law is a Harsh
Mistress and that the law is really kind
of my first love and that that it will
always be a distraction that when I'm
with you I will a lot of the time be
thinking about clients and cases and
every once in a while we'll be just
sitting there having a conversation and
all of a sudden my brain will go oh my
God that's a perfect question for cross-
examination I got to go write it down
and I was very as advertised about it
and um I have found in my relationship
having polarity is really important
having someone who is not who
understands the dedication and passion I
have for my work but who is the one who
says okay like that's great but now it's
time to come on like let's rest now like
let's it's okay we're gonna you're gonna
go back to it tomorrow morning I know
that but like you did a really good job
let's take can you give me a few hours
and if I go I can't I have a and they go
okay I get it but but who reminds me to
go like yeah okay it's okay to rest your
head you know so I think that that it's
as advertised and I listen I don't I
think connection the reason why I was
very cautious about when I said that to
Lex I was making a comment about the
nature of connection I don't know that
it has to be a romantic partner like I
have friends that have you know pets
friends a community a team a Jiu-Jitsu
Group whatever like that from which they
find deep love and connection I think
there is something hardwired in us and
very special about romantic love and I
don't even want to say the love between
a man and a woman because I I have lots
of gay and lesbian friends who have deep
deep satisfaction in their same-sex
relationships so I think there is
something very magical about love and
romance and sex I mean it's the it's why
we're here it's what keeps us going as a
species and it's you know most of us
will say like when you think back on
your life like some of the greatest
moments of your life were moments of
romantic connection sexual connection
any of those things so but I don't think
that that means like I have a mission
you know and it's just like that story I
said earlier about like when the guy
goes like she goes please don't go and
he goes yeah but I got to go like I do I
love my job I love my job I love the
woman in my life too would you get
married again she knows I marriage
doesn't mean anything to me like
marriage to me doesn't mean anything
it's a legal status you know it's like
would you go to the DMV only if I had to
you know like I don't see what that adds
to things like I don't when people say
would you get married again what they're
asking is would you have a monogamous
long-term relationship where you're
committed to this person deeply and
where you're the only and to me yeah
that's great I can't imagine life
without that I mean I guess I can't
imagine life without that but I'd work
more but it it it just you know it
wouldn't be as fulfilling of a life I
think love is really really an amazing
thing but I I know how I'm wired and I'm
weird I'm the first to admit it like I'm
not anybody's like I'm a strange guy
like I love my job in the most amazing
way and I don't think most people love
their work that way I got one I got one
last one really quick yeah why do you
think Joe Rogan has such a successful
relationship you know Joe is very
private about his marriage and every
single person who I know who knows him
personally through the Jiu-Jitsu
Community or through media things all
say that this is like a guy who loves
his wife and his wife really loves him
and that they also really like each
other but he's not super public about
the details of that marriage and and so
I think that's a really you know I I've
been wanting to app I've been a fan of
Joe's for years we've met before um in
the Jiu-Jitsu world I I've wanted to to
be a guest on his show because you know
talking with Lex was great and and and
sort of you know the natural Coral areas
you'd have a very different conversation
with Joe but the truth is like I I would
be very interested in hearing Joe's
answer to that question I just don't
know if Joe wants to share that with the
world and if he did I would love to hear
it and I'd love to be part of that
conversation and if he didn't I would
really respect and understand that too
that's a very personal choice but what I
what I can say is it looks like whatever
they're doing they're doing it right and
that that's what we should be looking at
is we should be looking at that iy I I
hope at some point he shares that either
with me or with the world even if it's
not with me like if he just shares it
with a different guest like I hope he
shares that with the world because
anytime somebody's doing it right and
both people in it are like man we're
doing it right I want to know I want to
know what they're doing like because I'm
on the other end I watch what everybody
does wrong and I'm reverse engineering
something from it but I would love to
hear what what Joe's doing right and I'd
love to hear I'd actually love to hear
what his what to me like when I
fantasize about that I'd love to sit
down with Joe Rogan and his wife and
hear from from their point of view what
it is that they're doing right I'd love
to hear what she says he's doing right
I'd love to hear what he says she's
doing right and I'd love you know I'd
love to know the truth of that but look
at the end of the day like there's so
many I'm whether you're a celebrity like
Joe is or whether you're just somebody I
pass on the street or a guy who's my
Uber driver I find people who are
happily married it's really cool to be
around them you know the next time
you're at a group you know dinner and
you ask people like so tell me how you
guys met watch how they light up when
they tell that story like that's it man
it's the greatest thing in the world
like that that warmth that comes off of
a couple when they're talking about like
yeah and she was there and she walked by
and I thought she was and you kind of
look at and you go like man it was 40
years ago or it was four months ago it's
just it's something great to behold so I
I anybody's story of how they fell in
love or how they stay in love I'm in I
want to hear it thank you so much Absol
thank you to WTF media Down Below in the
description for letting us use their
Studio I absolutely love it if you guys
like the way that the shots look the way
the audio sounds they basically did it
all what's your name Remy shout out Remy
he was cutting this entire thing that's
awesome really appreciate you for com
hopefully we do it again I would do I
wish could do another hours got to come
back we can do it anytime you want any
question anytime you're in the Big Apple
you guys have a divorce lawyer on on on
hold aome thanks so much thanks so much
thank you guys for watching till next
time